OKAY AT THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
COME THE ORDER. GOOD MORNING AS
WE CONTINUE TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND PROVIDE ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
PATIENT. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT BE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW DAYS PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING ROOM OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR MEETINGS- HERE IN
THE AT TEN TWENTY ONE POST
REBUILDING AND I ASK ALL MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. M. TO BE TO
BE PRESENT THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS. AND THIS
WILL AID IN US BEING ABLE TO
HEAR YOU. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OF IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED- AND LET'S. CALL
THE ROLL. EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN
HERE MELENDEZ PAN. WE NOTE THE
ABSENCE OF EVERYBODY BUT THE
CHAIR- BUT WE DO EXPECT SENATOR
PAN TO BE HERE SOON AND JUST AS
AN ANNOUNCEMENT THIS CHAIR HAS
TO LEAVE BY ELEVEN THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME SENATOR PAN WILL BE
TAKING OVER AND CHERRY THE
REMAINDER OF THE MEETING IF WE
HAVE NOT YET COMPLETED- WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SECTION OF THE
AGENDA TO GET TO TODAY. I WILL
BEGIN WITH A DISCUSSION OF THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUBMITTED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APRIL FINANCE
LETTER AND WITH US WE HAVE- G.
C. COOPER STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- WELCOME
AND PLEASE PROCEED. COOPER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. DCS IS REQUESTING
SIXTEEN A PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND FIVE YEAR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND SHOULD
MINISTER THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BRIDGE HOUSING PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES AND YET HOUSING AND
TREATMENT NEEDS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS WITH SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS THE
INVESTMENT IS DESIGNED TO
LEVERAGE THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY-
AND IS WELL ALIGNED WITH THE
CALLIN UP WHICH MODERNIZE AND
INCREASE THE SIMPLIFIES THE
MEDIC HOW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. FUNDING WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY DH CS AND MADE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES AND TRIBES
TO STAND UP IN OPERATE BRIDGE
HOUSING SETTINGS DH CS WILL USE
pOVERSIGHT ADD TO THAT COUNTY
TRIED TO ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS PROVIDE AS THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING NEEDED AND
LASTLY I'M- IT'S FUNDS TO HELP
DEVELOP. TRAINING IN THAT-
MATERIALS FOR THE GRANTEES AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. OR A FINANCING
ALMOST UNNOTICED MY COMMENTS
OKAY LMAO. THANK YOU SENATOR
EGGMAN ALCOR HIS SHEET- WITH THE
L. A. L. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
COMMENTS REYES ON ON THIS ITEM
AND JUST FOR THE SAKE OF-
STREAMLINING THINGS A LITTLE
BIT- WE ARE NOT PLANNING TO
RAISE ANY COMMENTS ON THE ISSUES
ON THE AGENDA UNTIL ISSUE ELEVEN
ON THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ENTERPRISE SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY SO MISS COOPER
THIS BASICALLY IS TO THE FOR OUR
FOR OUR BRIDGE HOUSING THAT THAT
WE'RE PRIORITIZING THIS WILL BE
THE STATE THE STATE KIND OF
HELPING OVERSEEING THE COUNTY'S
TRIBES AS THEY AS THEY DRAW DOWN
THESE RESOURCES AND THEN BEGIN
TO FILL THEM IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT THE RESOURCES ARE
REALLY TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRAINING- OVERSIGHT
OF THE FUNDS REPORTING OF THE
FUNDS OF FOR THE BRIDGE HOUSING
OKAY- AND THE HOUSING THAN THAT
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT BEFORE
THIS WILL BE A GRANT
APPLICATIONS OR JUST DIRECT
APPROPRIATIONS. WE'RE GONNA DO A
COMBINATION OF BOTH SO WE'LL DO
AN ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES AND
TRIBES IN THE ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONAL COMPETITIVE GRANT
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL SO WE'RE
DOING A TWO PRONGED APPROACH
WITH THIS ALLOCATION OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY. WE ALL HAVE
A LOT OF INTEREST IN MAKING SURE
THIS WORKS AS EFFECTIVELY. AS
POSSIBLE- JUST LET HERMAN ASKING
YOU A QUESTION ABOUT THIS OKAY
BECAUSE A IT'S AN ISSUE A MY DE
- BUT ONE THAT I JUST THINK IT'S
IT IS. ILLUSTRATIVE OF SOME OF
THE STRUGGLES THAT WE FACE
RIGHT. OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE SENDING DOWN A VERY
IMPORTANT- SO I REPRESENTS SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. THE COUNTY GOT I
THINK THREE OR FOUR MILLION. THE
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE GOT
ANOTHER YOU KNOW FEW MILLION- IN
ONE OF MY SMALLER TOWNS MANTECA
THEY ARE VERY VERY PROACTIVE
THEY PUT TOGETHER A NAVIGATION
CENTER THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD HOUSING FUNDING-
PROVIDE WRAP AROUND SERVICES AND
A SIXTEEN BED FACILITY IT COMES
WITH THAT A TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PRICE TAG. SO THAT
EXCEEDS EVERYTHING COUNTY HAS
BEEN ALREADY ALLOCATED IN THEIR
OF SMALL THE SMALLER TOWN- AND
SO AS I TRY TO HELP THEM FIND
BECAUSE I KEEP SAYING WE'RE
SENDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS DOWN. BUT IT WHEN I
TRY TO LOOK AT IT AND THINK
WHERE IT. HOW CAN I GET TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROJECT. THAT IS READY TO GO
RIGHT THIS MINUTE. AND I
COULDN'T FIGURE IT OUT EITHER
WITHOUT ME HAVING TO DO A
PERSONAL. ASK SO. CAN YOU HELP
ME WITH THAT. YES SO I WOULD
ACTUALLY RECOMMEND. LOOKING AT
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTINUE ON
DOLLARS WE'VE BEEN DOING GRANTS
AND ROUTE SO THE FIRST FEW
ROUNDS WERE FOCUSED ON MOBILE
CRISIS- AND SOME OTHER. SHOVEL
READY INITIATIVE- BUT WE ARE
GETTING READY TO LAUNCH THE NEXT
SERIES OF ROUTE THAT WILL HAVE.
LARGER DOLLAR AMOUNT
INITIATIVES. PROBABLY SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU ARE ARE MENTIONING-
THAT I SEE HIM UP HE WOULD BE.
ELIGIBLE TO SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION FOR- AND WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE THAT
APPLICATION I BELIEVE THE NEXT
ROUND COMING UP IS FOCUSED ON
CHILDREN USE BUT THEN WE HAVE
TWO ROUNDS AFTER THAT THAT WILL
BE BROAD BASED. A COMPETITIVE
APPLICATIONS AND I SWEAR I'D
RECOMMEND THEY FOCUS. MANY OF
THE YOU SOME OF THE FUNDS COMING
TO THE BRIDGE HOUSING BUT IT'S
REALLY MEANT TO BE. RAPID FIRE
OPERATING COSTS FOR IMMEDIATE
KIND OF A HOUSING WITH- YOU KNOW
WRAP SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE FACILITIES
YOUR MENTIONING. UNDER THE B. H.
THE I. P. PROGRAM THAT WE ARE
ALSO I'M DOING AND YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF RESOURCES. OF ONE
TIGHTENING AND PROCESSING TO BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO HAVE OUR-
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE SENATE.
OVER DIRECTLY TO YOU. THANK YOU
HI DEF MY SEVERAL. MAKE ME SHUT
UP ABOUT IT. OKAY AT THE DID YOU
ANYTHING ON THAT ISSUE ALL
RIGHT. OKAY MOVING ON TO ISSUE.
TWO THAN OPIOIDS. FUND OVERSIGHT
AND STATE DIRECTOR PROGRAMS.
RATE US SO HERE DH CS IS
REQUESTING. AT ELEVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF THIRTY THREE POINT NINE
MILLION- THAT FOR THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS- IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE A CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A NATIONAL LEADER IN AREAS
OF PREVENTION TREATMENT AND
RECOVERY SERVICES FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES.
INNOVATIONS INCLUDE THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
EXPANSION PROJECT OTHER DRUG
MEDI CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEM- CAL BRIDGE A MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SETTINGS ARE
NOT LEX OWN- DISTRIBUTION
PROJECT IN MANY OTHER PROJECTS
THE OPIOID SETTLEMENT OF FUNDING
WILL BE PROVIDED I WILL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE EXPANSION
OF INNOVATION AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL A DH CS NEEDS
RESOURCES TO CARRY OUT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OUTLINED IN THE
MACKENZIE DISTRIBUTORS. AND
JANSE VAN- SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS- AND TO ASSIST
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES AND
CITIES WITH LOCAL PLANNING
EFFORTS ON HOW TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED A
SERVICES AND PROJECTS AND
EXPANDING UP THE FUNDS IDEAS YES
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO MONITOR
REPORT CONDUCTED EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
OTHER COUNTIES AND CITIES ON THE
UTILIZATION OF THE OFFENDING.
OVER THE PROJECT. I THE B. THE
BCPS JUST FUNDING FROM THE-
JANUARY BUT- ADDED TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS OF THE REQUEST
INCLUDES A SHIFT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO DH CS OF NINETY. NINE
POINT TWO MILLION THE FUND AND
LAUNCH THE SHATTERPROOF
ADDICTION TREATMENT LOCATOR-
ASSESSMENT AND STANDARDS
PLATFORM ALSO KNOWN AS ATLAS I'M
INCLUDING AN AVERAGE CAMPAIGN-
TO RAISE AWARENESS ON THE NEW
RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT THAT AT
LUNCH AT SHATTERPROOF- IS- YOU
KNOW REALLY A DIRECTORY OF ALL
THE H. YES AS YOU PROGRAMS I DH
YES ARE YOU HOLDS A SHATTERPROOF
CONTRACT I TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT THE ATLAS-
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH IS WHY. OF
THAT IS BEING SHIFTED FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH TWO TWO DH CS
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL SHIFTS
TWENTY TWO MILLION TO INCREASE
THE WORKFORCE FOR OPIOID
TREATMENT OFFROM EACH CRIED TO
DH CS. OF THE SHIFT IS REALLY IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE CURRENT ONE
TIME FUNDING ON EFFORTS AT THE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING- WHERE WE HAVE
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER WORKFORCE
ACTIVITIES. IS OF COMBINING THE
TWO ALLOCATIONS TOGETHER ON IS
WHY THAT'S ALSO BEING SHIFTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. ALL CANADA'S BECAUSE IT
. HIDING NOTHING CREDIT OF A
WILL ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL ISSUES
. ABOUT ABOUT FAVORING ONE TYPE
OF THE MA TEES OVER OVER OTHER
TYPES CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT. SURE AT DH CS AS WE
COVER IN OUR MEDICARE ALIVE ALL
FDA APPROVED DRUGS AND SO WE AT
ALLOW REINFORCED AND AS A FOR
ALL ALL OPPORTUNITIES AND ALL OF
ALL DRUG TAX OKAY SO- INTENTION
IS AND IS TO IS TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S EQUITY ACROSS. YES THAT
IS CORRECT OKAY I THINK YOU WILL
WILL MAKE SURE THAT PAN. THANK
YOU WILLIAMS I'M CALLING FROM
THE SENATE THERE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY COMMENTS TO ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK
THANK YOU SORRY I MISSED THAT
PART OF THEMSELVES THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION- LIKE COUPLE
QUESTIONS- SO CERTAINLY. THIS IS
SAID PARTY PROPOSAL IS FOR
EXAMPLE SHIFTING SOME OF-
PROGRAMS FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
OVER TO DTS SO LET'S JUST TAKE
FOR EXAMPLE THE APPRECIATE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN ACTIVITIES FOR THE PART
IN PUBLIC HEALTH. SO DETACHED I
GUESS THE QUESTION THERE IS
THAT- IT YEAH I THINK PART
PERHAPS YEAH AND THE CONJECTURE
THAT ORIGINALLY WAS AND PART
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE THAT WAS
WHERE THE EXPERTISE MAY HAVE
MORE LANE IN TERMS OF DOING A
PUBLIC HEALTH A COMMUNICATIONS
CAMPAIGN- ARE WE JUST SHIFTING
MONEY OVER OF THE SHIFTING
PERSONNEL OVER WHO WERE
CURRENTLY PREVIOUSLY DOING THE
CAMPAIGN NOW JUST THE YOU KNOW
FROM ONE DEPARTMENT TO THE
OTHER- SO I IS SO IN TERMS OF
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TALK
ABOUT THE MONEY BUT I'M ALSO.
THINKING ABOUT THE EXPERTISE AND
CAPACITY CELLS THAT COMING OVER
FROM DPH ARE YOU TRYING TO BUILD
IT. AGAIN YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY
FROM GROUND UP CERTAINLY SEE YOU
SEE DTS HAS SOME EXPERTISE IN
COMMUNICATIONS BUT HE JUST BE A
LITTLE BIT. TO THAT. FIRST
THOUGH- YOU KNOW WE ARE ALREADY.
THE WITH SHOT IN. YEAH YOU LOOK
. IN THE CAMPAIGN WAS SPECIFIC
TO THE LAUNCHING OF THE- OF THE
THAT. YOU HAVE THE ADDRESS TO
ALL I TO ALL OF THE S. U. V.
PROVIDERS TO BENEFICIARIES MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE AWARE. OF HOW
TO USE THE TOOL AND HOW TO
ACCESS IT THE BIG REALLY GO HAND
IN HAND TOGETHER WHICH IS WHY
BOTH. THE DOLLARS FOR THE-
SYSTEM ITSELF AS WELL AS THE
CAMPAIGN AROUND THE LAUNCHING
OF. OF SHATTERPROOF I CAME TO DH
CS THE PAST COUPLE. OKAY BUT-
THIS IS PREVIOUSDID SO DID DPH
START THE CAMPAIGN OURS- NO
NOTHING EVEN STARTED THERE
THAT'S- BEEN STARTED WE HAVE THE
CONTRACT FOR THE SHATTERPROOF I
THINK IT WAS JUST THAT. A
SHIFTING OF. RESPONSIBILITY
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I
RELEASED YOU MAY REVISED SET TO
SHIP THOSE OVER TO THE H. YET.
WE HAD OUR STARTED THAT WORK
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I GUESS I
JUST AND YOU KNOW STATE
GOVERNMENT'S LARGE IS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT- CAPACITIES AND WITHIN
STATE GOVERNMENT SOMETIMES
SOMEBODY RESIDE SOME AGENCIES OR
OTHERS. SO I JUST THE- I. THAT
IN TURN OF WHY IT RICH WAS TO
DEEP H. IT'S AT A- SO I JUST
WANNA BE SURE. WE ARE. YOU KNOW
BUILDING THAT- YOU KNOW USING
CAPACITY THAT'S IN EXISTENCE AND
THE STATE GOVERNMENTS- TO DO
THAT AND CERTAINLY AND YEAH
THAT'S AND DTS CAN'T DO YOU
CAN'T DO THAT WORK. ITSELF AS
WELL BUT JUST- MIGHT BE SURE
THAT- WERE YOU KNOW GAIN DIRECT
PEOPLE DO THE RIGHT JOB SO. ALL
RIGHT BE SHE THAT- AND THEN THE
OTHER QUITE I HAVE IS. THAT IN
TERMS OF. THE WORKING ITSELF YOU
KNOW MY GOING TO STATE MY IS
GOING TO LOCALITIES. IN TERMS OF
BEING SURE THAT- SO WHAT KIND OF
ROLE IS THE STATE GOING TO I
MEAN I UNDERSTAND THAT THE- WHEN
THE LOCALES GET THE MONEY THEY
GET QUITE A BIT A SAY IN HOW
THEY SPEND THEIR MONEY. SO WHAT
KIND OF ROLE IS THE STATE GO
PLAY WITH WORKING WITH CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND SO FORTH FOR
THEIR- IN TERMS OF COORDINATING
TO BE SURE WE MAKE. VALUE BEST
USE OF THESE- DOLLARS. NOT SURE
THERE'S A LIST OF I THINK THAT
ARE ALLOWABLE TO THE FUNDS TO BE
USED IN THE- VARIOUS SETTLEMENTS
IN THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
COUNTIES ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT REGARDS TO
WHERE THE FUNDS. ARE USED OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT ALSO
OUTLINED A NUMBER OF OUR KEY
PRIORITY AREAS THAT WE WOULD BE
PROVIDING EITHER. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- EDUCATION OUR
RESOURCES TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN REGARDS TO YOU AYE THOSE
PRIORITIES- ADDITIONALLY I WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR- COLLECTING
DATA AND INFORMATION FROM EACH
OF THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
ANNUALLY AND POSTING THAT. ON DH
CS IS WEBSITES THAT WE WOULD BE
DOING A SERIES OF DATA
COLLECTION INFORMATION GATHERING
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES. I'M
COLLATING THAT INTO A REPORT
WHICH WOULD THEN BE A PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE SO THAT IS DOMINANTLY
THE ROLE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL WILL PLAY AND I'M SURE THE
WILL INVOLVE- IT PROBABLY BE A
PRETTY INTENSIVE IN THE FIRST
FEW YEARS. AND THEN HE WILL BE
ADJUSTING PRIORITIES AND FUNDS
AS WE CONTINUE TO GO ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED- IN THE
FURTHER OUT YOURS AS WELL WHICH
COULD INCLUDE SINCE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT IF WE WANTED TO
IDENTIFY YOU. STATEWIDE
PRIORITIES BUT WE WOULD DO THAT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTIES
AND CITIES A TO IDENTIFY OR SET
ANY NEW PRIORITIES IN THE FUTURE
AS WELL.OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT-
I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL TO BE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW EACH YEAR AS
WE DO THE BUDGET PROCESS. UPDATE
ON. OF COURSE THE STATE DOLLARS
BEING SPENT BUT THE OVERSIGHT
THAT YOU'RE DOING- FOR THE
WHOLE. SETTLEMENT IN REGARDS TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. COURSE THANK YOU MUCH
OKAY- ON TO A NUMBER. SUICIDE
PREVENTION VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUND. THANK YOU SO
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO.
OOPS THAT AS EXTRA PROVISIONS
APPLICABLE TO BE APPROPRIATED AS
SUICIDE PREVENTION VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUND- FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
DH CS EFFECTIVE JULY TWENTY TWO
THE PROPOSED AT YOUR CHANGES ARE
INTENDED TO ALIGN PROGRAM
SUPPORTING CRISIS CENTERS
LOCATED IN THE STATE OF THAT ARE
ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE NINETY DAY
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE OF WHICH WILL BE
EFFECTIVE JULY SIXTEENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- SPECIFICALLY
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD SHIFT BURKE-
PROGRAMMATIC RESPONSIBILITIES. I
TO DH CS A SINCE DH CS HAS THE
EXISTING CONTRACT TO SUPPORT THE
LIFELINE CRISIS CALL CENTER
NETWORK THAT IS ULTIMATELY AT
THE REASONING BEHIND THE SHIFT
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH A GRANT
PROCESS- THROUGH THE ANNUAL CALL
VOLUME AND REMOVED THE
REQUIREMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
REPORTING. A DH YES THEY
KNOWLEDGE IS THE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE- THE NEED OF THOSE IN
RURAL AREAS IN A DESERT
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA-
HOWEVER SINCE THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION CALL CENTER SERVICES
AREN'T MINISTER THROUGH THE
STATE CRISIS CALL CENTER NETWORK
I IN THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN
THE ANNUAL FUND IS RELATIVELY A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE CALL
CENTER NETWORK BUDGET ON IT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN MEASURE TO BE
DIFFICULT TO ASSURE 50% OF THE
DESIGNATED. OF DOLLARS UP OR
RURAL AND DESERT COMMUNITIES
THEREFORE DH YES IS PROPOSING TO
WORK WITH THE CALL CENTER
NETWORK TO ENSURE THE FUNDS ARE
PRIORITIZED FOR CALL CENTERS
SERVING IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I MOUNTAINS NOT TO ADD
TO YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO
HOW WILL WE ENSURE THEN I MEAN
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SAYING
WE CAN'T WE CAN'T INSURE 50%
BECAUSE- MARROW QUITE UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO THE
CRISIS CENTER SO. IT'S HARDER
THAN TO BE ABLE TO. TO GET THOSE
NUMBERS ARE WHY WHY IS IT MORE
DIFFICULT. BECAUSE THE CALLS ARE
GOING TO THE CALL CENTER. SURE I
THINK IT'S REALLY JUST BECAUSE
THE THIS THAT STATEWIDE NATURE
OF THE SERVICES THAT THEY WILL
BE ANSWERING I'M BUT LET ME ASK-
KELLY PFEIFFER HE'S CLOSER IN
ADD TO THIS IN REGARDS TO HOW WE
ARE WORKING WITH OUR VARIOUS
CRISIS CENTERS TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION MORE DIRECTLY KELLY CAN
YOU RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AS
YOU KNOW THERE'S A NETWORK OF
THIRTEEN CRISIS CALL CENTERS
THAT FORMER STATEWIDE CALL CALL
NETWORK AND THEY WERE
COLLABORATIVELY TO HAS A SHARED
MISSION TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALLS ARE ANSWERED. AND SOME OF
THEM CROSSED RURAL AREAS IN
URBAN AREAS SO WILL BE
CONTRACTING WITH THE READ-
CRISIS CALL CENTER IN
REPRESENTING THE NETWORK TO MAKE
SURE THE FUNDING IS. CRITICIZED
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES BUT IT
JUST WOULD HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT.
TO MAKE SURE WAS. EXACTLY
ALLOCATED TO THAT REPORTING BACK
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE PRETTY
SMALL- VOLUME YEAR TO YEAR SO
JUST THE AMOUNT OF MINISTRY OF
WORK IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN TO
ENSURE THAT RECORDED WITH A-
WHOLE FUNDING AWAY FROM. THE
NEEDED SERVICES. BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO TRACK IT AT
SOME LEVEL. HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
GOING. TOWARDS THE RULING
DOESN'T COMMUNITIES. WE BE ABLE
TRACK IT AND DOLLARS DOLLAR
THAT'S- WILL SET UP A CONTRACT
YOU JUST MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT. IS PRIORITY. FOR THOSE
CALL CENTERS THAT ARE I'M
SERVING THOSE COMMUNITIES. HI
THERE DEPEND. SO JUST TO CLARIFY
YOU SAID YOU CAN'T. TRACK IT.
BUT KEEP IN MIND THE CALL
CENTERS ARE PROPOSING- YOU YOU
KNOW FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OR SO
ABOUT WRITING CLASS FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR THIS FIND
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN LESS THAN
AMILLION DOLLARS SO OKAY WE
HAVEN'T YET WORKED OUT THE
CONTRACT DETAILS WE HEAR LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT SOME OF THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT AGAIN
WE JUST WORRY THAT IT COULD BE
SAID THE SMALL PERCENT YOUR
BUDGET YOU HAVE TO PUT IN
TRACKING MECHANISMS OF JUST OKAY
THURMOND THAT MADE ME FEEL STEP
BACK- I KNOW WHERE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE AND SO I GET WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT THIS IS
A SMALL SUBSET OF THE LARGER
FINE. IS THERE A WAY TO TRACK
WHAT PROPORTION OF THE SERVICES
OF THE CALLS OR SOMETHING ARE.
COMING FROM- YOU KNOW. A ROAD
HAZARD CRISIS CENTERS ARE WHAT
DEGREE. SICEL BUT I THINK THAT
THAT'S PROBABLY THE CRUX OF THE
MATTER IS WE'D LIKE TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE AREAS ARE BEING
ADEQUATELY SERVED SO IS THERE
SOME SORT OF. REPORTING
MECHANISM. FOUR I GUESS THIS IS
THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT PROGRAM-
WHICH WE CAN BE SURE THAT- ROLE
RURAL DESERT AREAS ARE BEING
ADEQUATELY SERVE SO WE CAN HAVE
SOME FEEDBACK AS TO. THE LEVEL
OF ACCESS HAPPENING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THROUGH- THROUGH NOT
ONLY OF COURSE THIS FINE BUT THE
LARGER PART OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
DEVOTING TO THIS. ABSOLUTELY SO
WE SET UP- METRICS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE TRACKING-HAD. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CALLS ARE
ANSWERED THAT WE'RE TRACKING-
CALL VOLUMES TO LOOK AT-
INEQUITIES IN THE LOOK AT
INEQUITIES- BY GEOGRAPHY AS WELL
REMAIN ISSUES THAT SOME OF THE
CALL CENTERS SERVE. RURAL AREAS
IN URBAN AREAS AND SO JUST BE
HARD TO SAY THIS PARTICULAR
DOLLAR HAS TO GO THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHY WHEN THE
CALL CENTERS COVERING THE WHOLE
AREA SO WE CAN DEFINITELY TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. ON THERE
NOW AND EVERYBODY'S GEOGRAPHIC
OKAY AND THEN THE CREW. AND
THEN. YOU CAN REPORT BACK
BECAUSE DONE THE NUMBER ON
NUMBER CRISIS CENTERS AND THE-
IN RURAL DESERT COMMUNITIES
RIGHT. SURE WE CAN HELP WE CAN
ACTUALLY CAN THIRTEEN CALL
CENTERS TO WE CAN. COME BACK TO
YOU SHOW. COMMUNITIES OF THOSE
CALL CENTERS REPRESENTS. OKAY
WELL I THINK THE IDEA AT LEAST
IN MY MIND IS THAT WE- EVEN IF.
YOU'RE SAYING MINISTRY LEE MAY
BE A LITTLE MORE CHALLENGING AND
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO INCREASE
OUR OVERHEAD AND TAKE MY MONEY
FROM SERVICES. BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO BE SURE WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN TERMS OF AT
LEAST THE I GUESS THE INTENT AND
SPIRIT OF WHAT THE ORIGINAL
REQUIREMENTS WORD THAT TO SHOW
THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE PAY
ATTENTION TO THOSE ONE BEATING
THOUGH SO I'M GLAD PRECIADO
PRIORITIZATION. I THINK SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY- IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT IN SOME REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THOSE. COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING YOU KNOW SERVE THE
PROBABLY AS AS EXPECTED AND NOW
THE ORIGINAL. STATUE RELEASE AND
SPIRIT. OF EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR THAT WERE MEETING THAT SO-
THAT SO YOUR HELP IN AND HELPING
US. DO THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY MOVING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSING FUND. IN
GREECE. THANK YOU DCS IS
REQUESTING TO INCREASE THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER OUR
RESIDENTS ARE LICENSURE AND
CERTIFICATION FEES DEPOSITED
INTO THE RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM LICENSING
FUNDS OTHER PROPOSED FEE
INCREASE IS NECESSARY BECAUSE OF
THE FEES FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO COVER COSTS.
INCREASED IS FROM APPROXIMATELY
45% OF THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET 263% IN THE
MAY REVISION AND DH CS IS
PROJECTING A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
I'M GOING BECAUSE OF PROJECTED
RATHER ARE INSUFFICIENT TO COVER
THE ESTIMATED EXPENDITURES AT
THIS TIME. OF FEES FOR THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
FACILITIES I WERE LAST INCREASED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN AND
SINCE THAT TIME NINE LEGISLATIVE
BILLS HAVE BEEN INACTIVE ARE
RESULTING IN AN INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND EXPENDITURES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY ONE POSITIONS
WITHOUT AN INCREASE TO THE FEES
OF THE FUND- WAS IMPACTED BY
PROGRAM CLOSURES AND REQUEST FOR
FEE WAIVERS DUE TO THE- A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. ARE THE
CURRENT THANK YOU NO LONGER
SUPPORT THE H. YES EXISTING
STATUTORILY REQUIRED LICENSING
OVERSIGHT WITHOUT A FEE INCREASE
THAT HAPPENED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU. OKAY- FOR. AND
THAT'S AS IT DEPARTS OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO OKAY AND EVERY WORK
WITH THE WITH THE RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS DISK THE FEE AT ME THEY
KNOW THIS IS. YES IT WAS A PART
OF THE OF THE PREVIOUS GOVERNORS
BUDGET WE'RE MAKING-
MODIFICATION- HERE IN REGARDS TO
THE PROPOSED CHANGE- AND BELIEVE
THAT I TELL YOU FIVE OR THIRTEEN
HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
DATE OF DISABILITIES. OKAY AND
THE FACILITIES DON'T FEEL LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE IN AND-
IMPEDIMENT TO BEING ABLE TO OPEN
UP. NEW FACILITIES IN A TIMELY
MANNER. KELLY I WILL DEFER TO
YOU IN REGARDS TO THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
HAD. YEAH WE- THEY ARE NOT HAPPY
WITH THE FRANKLY BECAUSE IT IS
CHALLENGING TIMES FOR THEM IN
TERMS OF- MAINTAINING ADEQUATE
WORKFORCE RESPONDING TO
INCREASED DEMAND EMERGING FROM
THE PANDEMIC. AND THEY WE HAVE
BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH THEM
ABOUT THE NEESSITY OF IT AND
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
GIVEN HOW ARE FEES ARE
STRUCTURED IN THE REQUIRED TO
BE. SELF SUPPORTING. OKAY I MEAN
TO DEMEAN. THAT THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC IS AS WE'RE TRYING
TO OPEN OPEN UP MORE FACILITIES
IF THE IF THE LICENSURE AND
CERTIFICATION FEES ARE GOING TO
BE. AN IMPEDIMENT SO WE'LL HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT-
MIKE PENCE. BUT SO YOU MENTIONED
A PART OF THE REASON FOR THE-
FOR THE FARM FUND IS ACTUALLY
BECAUSE YOU HAD TO GIVE A FEE
WAIVERS AND OTHER- ACTIONS-
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC DID I
HEAR THAT CORRECTLY. YES IS
MULTI FACTORIAL THEY HAD ME
WE'VE HAD SOME SOME FACILITIES
CLOSE AS THE SEVENTIES DURING
THE PANDEMIC STATES FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP AND GET A FEW WAIVERS
BUT HONEST THE BIGGEST. ISSUE IS
LEGISLATIVE BILL THAT IS ASKING
US TO STEP UP OVERSIGHT
MONITORING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH STAFF
COST AND SO- WEEK AND NOT REYES
WE DON'T HAVE ANY MECHANISM TO
RAISE FEES BASED ON ACTUAL
LITERALLY WE JUST GOT IN. SO THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT OF SO
SOUNDS LIKE YOU SAID THERE'S
THREE FACTORS RIGHT SO ONE IS
CLOSURES SO OBVIOUSLY CLOSED SO
HE DOESN'T PAY ANY FEES. TO IS
YOU HAVE FACILITIES UNDER STRESS
AND SO THEY'RE ASKING FOR FREE
WAIVER SO IT CAN CONTINUE
OPERATING WHICH YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT NAZARIAN APPROPRIATE THE
THIRD YOU SAID OF COURSE IS
INCREASED COSTS RELATED TO
INCREASE REQUIREMENTS THAT MIGHT
IMPACT THE LEGISLATURE. OTHER
REASONS. CAN YOU. SO IN TERMS OF
THE- AND THE FEE WAY. CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT PERCENTAGE OF I
GUESS. THE S. LICENSEES WILL
FALL UNDER THAT CATEGORY- IN THE
LESS SO THAT THEY TWO YEARS AGO
WE HAD HOW MANY LICENSEES AND
THEN WE'VE LOST HOW MANY
FORECLOSURES AND HOW MANY HAVE.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THOSE ARE
CLOSE AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE HAVE GOTTEN FEW WAIVERS.
EVERY AT LEAST GIVE ME A ROUGH
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE IS ARE WE
TALKING LIKE 10% 20% 30% 50% IT
IS A SMALL NUMBER OF CLOSURES
RELATIVELY. AFFECTS YOUR VERY
SPECIFIC OKAY. SO SMALL NUMBERS
TO SMALL AT THE END OF FIVE
PERCENTAGE UNDER TEN PERCENTAGE
. YES LED TO GET BACK TO YOUR
EXACT OKAY AND THEN IN A FEW
WAIVERS REPRESENT ROUGHLY WHAT
PERCENTAGE IS THAT. AGAIN I NEED
TO GET BACK TO THE- AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCLAMATION I DON'T
PROMISE YOU I WON'T HOLD YOU
DIRECTLY TO THE EXACT NUMBER-
BUT ARE WE ARE WE LOOKING AT
THIRD ARE WE LOOKING AT. 10% ARE
WE LOOKING AT HALF. YEAH I WHAT
I IN MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
WORKING WITH MY TEAM CLOSELY ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE DOES THAT AS HAPPY TO
INCREASE FEES AS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE WAS THAT. GRADUALLY OF
STAFF AND INCREASED WITH EVERY
LEGISLATION THAT PASSED WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO COME WITH
AND THAT'S THE BIGGEST IMPACT.
BUT I AM IN THE FEE WAIVERS AND
THE CLOSURES MUCH SMALLER
CONTRIBUTORS THAT CAN DEFINITELY
GET BACK TO AMERICANS. ALL RIGHT
SO I THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO SORT
OF BREAK THAT DOWN AND- GIVE US
FEEDBACK ON THAT. BECAUSE OF THE
WEEK YEAH WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A- A POTENTIALLY- I GOT SELF
HEATING CYCLE IF WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT. WE HAVE CLOSURES AND FEE
WAIVERS WHICH THEN OF COURSE
DECREASES NUMBER PEOPLE ARE
PAYING FEES AND WE'RE TELLING
THEM WE'RE GONNA INCREASE YOUR
FEES. ETCETERA AND THEN OF
COURSE THEN THAT MAKES MORE
FACILITY SAY HEY WE NEED THE
WAIVERS AT CETERA RIGHT BECAUSE
NOW THESE ARE HIGHER. SARAH SO
THAT'S THAT THAT WOULD BE A SELF
REINFORCING CYCLE THAT WE WOULD
NOT WANT TO GET INTO SO I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW. SB SELF
SUSTAINING GOT THAT- BUT ALSO
WANT TO BE SURE WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE DRIVERS BEHIND THIS SO
THAT WE DON'T CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE ACTUALLY AS WE ARE HAVING
GREATER NEED FOR THEIR SERVICES
THAT WERE ACTUALLY DRIVING DOWN
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS. AND AND
SO WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND OUR
ROLE IN IN THAT. SO IF YOU CAN
HELP US PROVIDE SOME ANALYSIS OF
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
AND I KNOW L. A. L. SAID THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO COMMENT UNTIL.
ITEM ONE OF ELEVEN OR SOMETHING
BUT- IF THEY'RE LISTENING I PRAY
ASK THEM IF THEY COULD HELP US
OUT WITH TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
AGAIN- WE- THE ROLE DIFFERENT
THESE ASPECTS OF THAT. SO THEY
WE CAN APPROACH. ADDRESS THE
CITY WHETHER WE TO. PLACE
TEMPORARY SUBSIDIZE. THIS THIS
FUND BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OR- ARE SIMPLY DO
A FEE INCREASES YOU'RE PROPOSING
IT CETERA BUT WE- I THINK THE WE
NEED TO LOOK. MORE BROADLY OUR
POLICY OPTIONS BE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT CREATING A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY DRIVING
DOWN. THE VERY. PROVIDERS THAT
WE NEED. THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE BUDGET AND
OTHER LEGISLATION TRYING TO
DRIVE UP. SO INCREASE CAPACITY
THANK YOU. YEAH I WOULD- I
WOULD. ECHO THAT SEEM THAT SEEM
CONCERNED AND IF. IF WE ARE
LIMITED BECAUSE THE- IT NEEDS TO
BE SELF SUSTAINING THEM PERHAPS
WE JUST WE NEED TO LOOK. AT THAT
ISSUE ITSELF- AND FIGURE OUT
MAYBE A DIFFERENT. JUST TOTALLY
FEE DEPENDENT. BECAUSE IT DOES
SEEM TO BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
OUR ULTIMATE GOALS. OF GETTING
MORE PEOPLE IN INTO. NOT THE
STREETS AND INTO TREATMENT AND-
AND MEETING THOSE TO BE
EFFECTIVE SO- WILL WILL HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT AND
AGAIN I WOULD A GOOD DOCTOR
PANTS REQUEST OF LA WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT. AND MAYBE PROVIDE
US WITH SOME MORE POLICY OPTIONS
TO CHOOSE FROM IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO. BETTER STRUCTURE THAT
FUND. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FIVE A
MEDIC CAL TELEHEALTH POLICY. OR
ALSO AFTER THE ONSET OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY DH YES
IMPLEMENTED- A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF OUR ROWLEY'S COULD
CONTINUE RECEIVING ACCESS TO
SERVICES- WHEN IN PERSON
ENCOUNTERS WERE NOT RECOMMENDED
AT THAT TIME OR WERE NOT
AVAILABLE OF ALL OF OUR POST
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY POLICIES
WHICH ARE IN OUR PROPOSAL- SAID
YES YES HAS PUT FORWARD- REALLY
GROUNDED IN SEVEN KEY PRINCIPLES
AND I MENTIONED THAT JUST
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THEY
REFLECT GONNA HOW WE FELT THE
PROPOSAL ON HOW WE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- IT INCLUDES EQUITY
ACCESS STANDARD OF CARE YOU
SHOULD CHOICE CONFIDENTIALITY
STEWARDSHIP. AND PAYMENT
APPROPRIATENESS AND WE REALLY
USE THOSE TO KIND OF GROUND THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD AS YOU
ARE AWARE WE ARE HELD A
TELEHEALTH ADVISORY AYE WORKERS
BASED ON LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
AGREEMENTS I WHICH CONSISTED OF
A NUMBER OF SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS ARE WE CAN BE NOT A
VERY- ON A REGULAR BASIS
ULTIMATELY. AS I. DO THE REPORT
END OF LAST- FOR THEIR ALLEGED
AND OTHERS TO UNDERSTAND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
THAT WERE TALK ABOUT WITHIN
THAT- TELEHEALTH OF WORKGROUP.
AND THAT IS POSTED ON DH THE
ESSENCE WEBSITE AND THEN AS A
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
RELEASED OUR TELEHEALTH POLICY.
INCLUDING TRAILER BALL. ALTHOUGH
I JUST DO A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING DID
NOT. ANSWER THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING- TO MAINTAIN MANY OF
THE POLICIES THAT WERE
INTRODUCED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. INCLUDING THE
CONTINUATION OF COVERAGE OF
SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO AUDIO ONLY AN
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH COVERAGE
ACROSS MULTIPLE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS- EVEN INCLUDING MANY OF
OUR WAIVER PROGRAMS. ON BUT ALSO
ACROSS OUR BROAD MEDICARE
PROGRAM BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO
CONTINUE ON PARITY AND
REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS BETWEEN IN
PERSON SERVICES- AND SELECT A
TELEHEALTH MODALITIES INCLUDING
SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO SYNCHRONOUS
AUDIO ONLY- AND ASYNCHRONOUS A
STORM BOARDS ESSENTIALLY. IN THE
PARITY ACROSS THE BAY AREA IS A
MAIN TELEHEALTH MODALITIES RASO-
I RECOMMEND YOU TO REMOVE THE
SITE LIMITATIONS FOR THREE
SEASON RUN HEALTH CLINICS. I
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE LOOKING AT-
AND PROPOSING TO ALLOW ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW PATIENTS
ONLY THROUGH. IN PACE SET IN
PERSON FACE TO FACE- OR
SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO. SERVICES AS
THE ESSENTIALLY THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING TO YOU
NOT ALLOW FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF NEW PATIENT PATIENTS ONLY
SAYING AUDIO ONLY OR AB
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH. AND IN
CONSULTATION WITH MANY OTHER
MEDICAID DIRECTORS THIS IS A
PRETTY CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
STATE ARE THERE ARE VERY FEW
THAT ARE ALLOWING AUDIO ONLY FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW
PATIENTS AT THIS TIME- WE DO.
RECOMMEND THIS BECAUSE WE DO
THINK IT WILL BE TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE BY STEP MACHINE
YOU PATIENTS VIA TELEHEALTH. IN
PERSON. AND AS AT THE VIDEO- HOW
WE ARE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE WE
ARE THE OF. TO I DIDN'T OF THE
PAGE AND- THERE BY IMPROVE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY ENSURING THE
DEEPER LEVEL OF INITIAL OF
PATIENT PROVIDE CAN. AND
RELATIONSHIP- DURING THAT
INITIAL VISIT ON THE OFTEN
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL SIGNIFICANT
EVALUATION OR ASSESSMENT THEN
AWESOME THE FOLLOW UP VISIT.
ADDITIONALLY THROUGH THOROUGH
DISCUSSION WITH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE- AT STAKEHOLDERS WE
MADE ONE EXCEPTION WHICH IS
NOTED IN OUR PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY OF REFUGEES RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS AROUND THE
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH. OF FOR
THE VIRTUAL DENTAL HOME SO WE
HAVE MADE THAT EXCEPTION WITHIN
OUR RECOMMENDATION AND IS NOT
REFLECTED IN OUR AT TRAILER BILL
AS WELL. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THE USE OF SPECIFIC MODIFIERS TO
IDENTIFY THE TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES. USED OF INCLUDING
INDUCTION OF THE- NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED CPT CODES FOR AUDIO
ONLY VISITS I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
DATA POSSIBLE I TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT OUT FUTURE- YOU KNOW
QUALITY. IMPACTS OF TELEHEALTH
ACCESS TO THE DIFFERENT
MODALITIES- AND SO WE AT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THAT. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO ENHANCE A PATIENT
PROTECTIONS AS A RELATIVE TO
TELEHEALTH. INCLUDING
STRENGTHENING CONSENT LANGUAGE
FOR PATIENTS INCLUDING THE RIGHT
TO FACE TO FACE AS SERVICES I
USE OF TELEHEALTH OF BEING AT
THE OPTION OF THE BENEFICIARY IS
REALLY CRITICAL HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. HOW IMPORTANT THAT
WAS ADDITIONALLY ENSURING
BENEFICIARIES RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON THE AVAILABILITY
OF TRANSLATION SERVICES AND
MAKING SURE THAT THAT IS
CONTINUALLY BEING OFFERED WHEN
TELEHEALTH IS BEING OFFERED AS
WELL JUSTICE WAS REQUIRED WHEN
SOMEONE WAS IN AN IN PATIENT.
IMPATIENCE SORRY IN PERSON
VISIT. ADDITIONALLY I WE ARE ALL
OF RECOMMENDED TO PHASE IN A
REQUIREMENT THAT NO SOONER THAN
A TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- THAT
PROVIDERS ARE OFFERING.
INDIVIDUALS THE CHOICE ABOUT
VIDEO. OR AUDIO ONLY THEY ARE
DUE BOTH SO THE BE IN. OF TO.
AND THE I- ONLY OPTIONS ARE IT'S
JUST MAKING THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE A CHOICE. OF THE DIFFERENT
TYPES. I TELL OP OF FOR THEM.
AND THEN AT WE ARE LOOKING TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE BY
ALLOWING OUR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS THAT'LL HELP PLAN AND
OUR DMC OF THE S. OR S. U. V.
OUR PLANS TO BE ABLE TO. USE
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE AUDIO
VIDEO SYNCHRONOUS INTERACTIONS
IN REGARDS TO THEIR NETWORK
ADEQUACY STANDARDS AT TIMES IN
DISTANT STANDARDS SO ESSENTIALLY
WE WOULD BE DOING IT THROUGH THE
NETWORK ADEQUACY UPFRONT NOT
JUST THE ALTERNATE ACCESS WHICH
I. STATE LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS
FOR I WILL ALSO BE PUTTING IN A
NUMBER OF MONITORING ON THAT-
EFFORTS AS WE ARE EXPANDING IN
USING THESE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MODALITIES- AND SERVICES AND
WILL CONTINUE TO YOU. ARE BUILD
OUT THAT RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
PLAN THAT IS DUE BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR ADD TO THE PUBLIC WE
HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION WITH
YOU ABOUT YOUR GROUP IN REGARDS
TO WHAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON IN
THE EVALUATION. OF INCLUDING-
YES ACCESS TO CARE FOR DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS MAKING SURE WE'RE
LOOKING AT DISPARITIES ACROSS-
OF THE VARIOUS TELEHEALTH USAGES
AND IMPACTS TO CLINICAL OUTCOMES
OF AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOU- AD POSTING FOR COMMENT OUR
EVALUATION PLAN. OUT LATER THIS
YEAR I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THE
PROGRAM FINANCE. LARA AYE
ELEANOR COMING AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE IMAGE
COOPER DID YOU. TALK ABOUT THE
DONE TO ALSO ASK YOU TO TALK
ABOUT THE CHANGES PROPOSED IN IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEELS LIKE
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY- WHERE
THIS WAS A HUGE ISSUE OF
CONTROVERSY LAST YEAR NOW IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE- WE'RE
COMINGTHROUGH IT IT WITH OPEN
ARMS IN A DIFFERENT KIND OF WAY
NOW. I THINK YOU KNOW I THINK WE
HAVE SOME REALLY GREAT
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ADVISORY
GROUP- AND I THINK. YOU KNOW
ONCE WE ARE REALLY WERE ABLE TO
OUTLINED SOME OF THE-
BENEFICIARY PROTECTIONS THAT WE
ALL OF. A MUTUALLY AGREED ON
WERE SO CRITICAL FOR- INCREASING
ACCESS TO TELL BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT BENEFICIARIES HAVE.
CHOICES AND RIGHT IN THEIR
EDUCATED AROUND OF THESE PIECES-
AND SOME OF THE OTHER PIECES
THAT WE PUT IN HERE WE FELT
PRETTY COMFORTABLE WITH OUR
CURRENT PROPOSAL. AND HAVE
REALLY APPRECIATED A LOT OF THE
TIME THAT PEOPLE PUT IN- IN
THOSE WORK GROUPS WITH US. A TO
REALLY DIG IN AND THE
RECOMMENDATION FORWARD SO YES WE
HAVE THE BIGGEST CHANGES WERE
AROUND BENEFIT YOUR PROTECTIONS-
AND- REALLY GETTING TO A PLACE
WHERE- WHERE WE LANDED ON BOTH.
THE ACROSS THE BOARD- AS WELL.
GOOD A IT'S IT. IT'S BEEN A
GREAT PROCESS. I THINK TO BE
ABLE TO WATCH. THEM GET IT GOING
TO THE PANDEMIC AS WE IT WAS WE
START LOOKING ALL KINDS OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. AND THEN I THINK
WE'VE REALLY. IT'S REALLY GONE
FOR TO CONTINUE TO TRANSFORM OUR
SYSTEMS IN A WAY. THAT BEING AND
BEING ABLE TO USE EXPERIENCE IN
THE DATA AND PEOPLE REALLY
COMING TOGETHER TO WORK ON SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YEAH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION REALLY WHY I THINK-
DTS AN ADVISER FOR ME FOR THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE. REALLY
APPRECIATE- THAT PRESENTATION
AND WHAT CAME UP WITH. I GUESS
THE ONE TIME AND I WOULD JUST
MAKE IT IS THAT- AND AGAIN
GROUP- LET'S SEE THESE. NOT
BEING ACTUALLY PUT IN THE
LANGUAGE DOES MAKE IT PERMANENT-
MOVING FORWARD. IT'S JUST
RECOGNIZE WHENEVER DALY
TELEHEALTH THAT THERE'S TWO ENDS
RIGHT- SO NORMALLY WE HAVE A-
COUNTER AND SOMEONE COMES THE
OFFICE AND COURSE YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOT TO DEAL TRANSPORTATION OTHER
THINGS IN TERMS OF PEOPLE GAIN
ACCESS THAT WAY- THAT- AS MUCH
AS- A PROVIDER HALLETT THE
CLINIC HOSPITAL PRACTICE
WHATEVER IT CAN. TRY TO SET UP
THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR THEIR- SET
UP THAT- WE HAVE A LOT OF
PATIENTS WHO DON'T HAVE VERY
GOOD ACCESS TO WHETHER IT'S
INTERNET TO OUR EQUIPMENT OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS AND SO. AS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO TO-
YOU KNOW IMPROVE THAT THEIR
ACCESS TO THAT CONNECTIVITY'S SO
REALLY DO APPRECIATE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'LL- AND I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT YOU KNOW IF THE
STAB WISHING CARE AND SO FORTH
AND HAVING CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS-
AND NOT. DOING WHAT IDEA ONLY OR
SOMETHING BUT THEN. STILL ARE
YOU KNOW SAYING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO. REIMBURSE FOR AUDIO
ONLY LIVING YOU KNOW- LATER ON.
BUT JUST RECOGNIZING THAT. THERE
MAY BE BOTH NOW I TECHNOLOGICAL
BUT ALSO CIRCUMSTANTIAL- MAIL SO
WE ONLY TALK ABOUT. WHAT
SITUATIONS OTHER SITUATIONS
WHERE- WHERE WE. MAY WANT TO
THINK ABOUT- IT YEAH HOW WE THE-
AT THEIR- TO STILL BE ABLE TO
ADD. TELL WHILE NOT JEOPARDIZING
THEIR SAFETY WHILE NOT REQUIRING
THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE YOU KNOW
CONNECTIVITY THAT MAY NOT BE SO
AVAILABLE IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD IN
YOUR COMMUNITY. UNLIKE PERHAPS A
YOU KNOW. A MIDDLE CLASS
HOUSEHOLDER SO FORTH AND I KNOW
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THESE
THINGS BUT I THINK THAT'S GOING
TO BE CONTINUING WORK MOVING FOR
BUT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS. THAT'S BEEN MADE AND
SOUNDS LIKE SOME SUBSTANTIAL
WORK THAT WE'RE GOING TO. MAKE
ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH A MEDIC
CAL- PERMANENT MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
SIX AND- DURING A PRESENTATION-
DRUG COOPER I AM GOING TO BE
LEAVING AND DOCTOR PANEL BE.
TAKING OVER AS CHAIR ASSEMBLY
VIEW IN GOOD HANDS- SO THANK YOU
ISSUE NUMBER SIX PLEASE. OR
THANK YOU. DO YOU SEE S. IS
REQUESTING OTHER LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN EACH
POSITION- AS WELL AS CONTRACT
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY EQUAL TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND WINDING IN
THE REDETERMINATION WORK THAT
THE COUNTIES I WILL NEED TO
COMPLETE. OF THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
ACROSS TWO YEARS RELATED TO
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH. OUR PROCESSING
OF THE REDETERMINATION CASELOAD
ADDITIONALLY DH CS HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
BALLPLAYERS DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ON ASSESSING THE
WORK FLOW FOR COUNTIES THROUGH
COUNTY SURVEYS. IDC HAS WILL BE
EVALUATING THE RESULTS OF THE
RECENT I COUNTY SURVEYS ON
RESOURCES AND COLLABORATE WITH
THE WGA ON NEXT STEPS. WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH THEM ON
PROVIDING GUIDANCE AND TOOLS FOR
COUNTIES I TO ASSESS THEIR
READINESS OF FOR THE UNWINDING
ACTIVITIES ARE THAT THEY MUST
UNDERTAKE. WHILE STILL
ADDRESSING UPCOMING APPLICATIONS
AND ONGOING MANAGEMENT OF
EXISTING AKKI SAYS. AS AS YOU'LL
SEE IN THE PROPOSAL DH CS IS
ALSO I WANTED TO TAKE A
PROACTIVE APPROACH- IN REGARDS
TO A LARGE A STEEP WIDE.
UNIFICATION CAMPAIGN AROUND THE
UNWINDING I TO ENSURE THAT THE
POPULATION ANYONE WHO NEEDS A
COVERAGE. BUT AS ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT FOR MEDIC CAL OR
TO SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION TO
COVER CALIFORNIA OR EMPLOYER
BASED COVERAGE. I'M IN REALLY
LOOKING TO YOU I WORK WITH AN
EXPERIENCED VENDOR WHO WOULD
HELP DEVELOP IT EIGHTY EDUCATION
ARE AND OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN WE HAVE
ROLLED OUT FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THESE PIECES OF WHERE WE WILL
HAVE OUR DH CS A COVERAGE
INVESTORS WE HAVE HAD. MULTIPLE
PEOPLE SIGN UP FOR OUR-
AMBASSADORS- I THINK WE ARE
CLEARLY IN THE HIGHER NUMBER BUT
RENEE IF. YOU COULD SEND ME OUT
THE NUMBER OF THAT COME YEAH
MASSACRES THAT FIND OUT THAT
WOULD BE THANK I'M A- THAT
REALLY. OF MOVIE WORK WITH THE
VENDOR TO REALLY- CULTURAL OF.
COMMUNITY CAMP. ARE THAT WE
WOULD OUT. I WE HAVE A BASED ON
MAILINGS ABOUT A 12% OF OUR
MEDICARE ABOUT A BENEFICIARIES
ARE CURRENTLY- DO NOT HAVE AN
UPDATED ADDRESS ON FILE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE HAVE NOW
GONE WHAT'S CLOSE TO TWO AND A
HALF YEARS. OR TWO PLUS YEARS OF
NOT DOING BE DETERMINATIONS ON
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT CURRENT
FOR MANY OF OUR- BENEFICIARIES-
AND SO WE- ARE. WORKING TO DO A
TWO PART CAMPAIGN THE FIRST ONE
IS A REALLY WORKING WITH OUR
COVERAGE INVESTORS I'M GETTING
THE WORD OUT I TO BENEFICIARIES
TO PLEASE UPDATE THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION THEIR NAME ADDRESS
PHONE NUMBER. EMAIL WITH THEIR
COUNTY- WE HAVE MULTIPLE TOOL
KITS THAT WE HAVE SENT OUT
BROADLY ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER ALSO POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE SO THEY CAN BE
DOWNLOADED. I'M IN MANY- OF
LANGUAGES- AND THAT THE FIRST
PHASE THAT WE'RE IN AND WE WILL
BE IN THAT PHASE AND TELL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GIVES US
SIXTY DAY NOTICE THAT WE WILL
BE. ENDING V. AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN WHICH CASE WE WOULD
IMMEDIATELY TRANSITION OUR A
CAMPAIGN TO ENCOURAGING
BENEFICIARIES TO CONTINUE
UPDATING THEIR- CONTACT
INFORMATION BUT ALSO CHECK IN
THEIR MAIL FOR THE RENEWAL
PACKETS THAT WOULD BE COMING
FROM THEIR COUNTIES AND DOING.
EXTENSIVE OUT REACH THERE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN AS YOU EDUCATE OUR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES IN
REGARDS TO THE UPCOMING A
POTENTIAL WE DETERMINATIONS. AND
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH MANY PEOPLE ON THIS AND THE
TEAM DID GET BACK TO ME WE ARE
NOW OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AT DH CS-
AND AMBASSADORS WORKING WITH US
ON THIS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME
UPCOMING. TRAININGS AND WEBINARS. FOR THEM AS WELL AND SO WE
LOOK FOR. DURING WITH EVERYONE
SHARE THE ANYONE WHO NEEDS.
REMAINS COVER. AS WE ARE. IN THE
FUTURE AND HAVE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. RIGHT THANK
YOU OF FINANCE. DTLA DEAN THERE
. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
AND I BELIEVE- WE DON'T GET TO
LA- YET SO- NO THANK YOU EIGHT
EIGHT- CERTAINLY THIS IS GOING
TO BE CRITICAL- AND THE- FACT
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE. ADDRESSES
412% TO LOW LOW LOW WORRISOME-
BUT- I THINK I KNOW THAT ALSO
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE MOVE A LOT
IT'S- DIRECTED DON'T ALWAYS GET
BACK TO YOU SOMEONE WHO TAKES
pCARE OF MEDICAL PATIENTS- LAB
HAVE UNSTABLE HOUSING.
SITUATIONS AND OF COURSE- WITH
THE PANDEMIC- THERE'S ALSO BEEN
A LOT OF JOBS SHIFTING AS WELL
WHICH THEN RESULTS AND
POTENTIAL. HILL ALSO MOVEMENT AS
WELL. SELL IT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL- IN TERMS
OF BEING SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. WELL I DEARLY WE TRY TO OF
EVERYONE A WARM HAND OFF TO SOME
FORM OF COVERAGE IF THEIR
QUALIFY FOR THAT. BUT I THINK
THE FIRST PART OF THE JOB IS
ACTUALLY. TO CHECK HIS TO- THAN
A FIVE HELLO WHERE THEY ARE. AND
SO FORTH- SO- SO IT. SO I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE REALLY BORED
OKAY WELL- ALL RIGHT. OKAY WELL
CERTAINLY WHAT WOULD THAT
PRECIADO IS WHEN YOU KNOW WHEN
THIS HAPPENS HOPEFULLY NOT TOO
SOON- BUT- WHEN IT DOES
EVENTUALLY HAPPEN THAT- OF
COURSE TO KEEP US UPDATED AS TO
THE PROGRESS AND HOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO.
IDENTIFY WHAT WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM SO THAT THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. OKAY ANYTHING ELSE
ON THIS. BILL OKAY. ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THEN- THE- CAL
IMPLEMENTATION. GREAT IDEAS YES
IS REQUESTING A HUNDRED AND SIX
POSITIONS- AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL FUN A FIFTY THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO FURTHER SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE CALLIE%
AND AN ISSUE DID- AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR WE ARE VERY EXCITED TO
ADD THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
APPROVED- CALLEN BUT THE
NINETEEN FIFTY BE AN ELEVEN
FIFTEEN- THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
A NEW S. T. CAESAR WITH A
SPECIAL TERMS AND CONDITIONS-
THAT- WE AGREED TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT RESULTED
IN- AT NEW WORKLOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WAS NOT
PREVIOUSLY. I SUBMITTED IN AND
PRIOR BCPS I'M IT ALSO INCLUDED
SOME CONTINUATION OF EXISTING
OUR WORK LOAD- FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS LIKE OUR GLOBAL PAYMENT
PROGRAM AND CMS WANTED TO
CONTINUE THE EVALUATION FOR
EXAMPLE. ARE WE ALSO A NOTATED
IN OF THIS REQUEST AS SOME OF
THE INITIATIVES THAT WERE
FURTHER DEVELOPED AS IN THE
PREVIOUS- POSITIONS WERE
PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT LIKE
OUR JUSTICE PACKAGE AND OF THE
CURRENT A SPECIALTY OF MENTAL
HEALTH I AM DEVELOPER THAT WE
ARE- FOR THE- OF BUILDING. AND
PLANNING AT THIS TIME. YOU ALSO
A C. THAT- THERE WAS QUITE
EXTENT ISSUE OF. WITH THE
AMBASSADOR. TO A ENSURING THAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON MONITOR IN
OVER. OF OUR VERY MANAGED ENTITY
. I'M INCLUDING MEDIC MANAGED
PLANS SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
INDIAN CO DS PLANTS AND THEN OF
COURSE OUR DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS AS WELL- THERE WERE
REQUEST SPECIFICALLY AROUND ON
INDEPENDENT ACCESS ASSESSMENTS
FOR ALL OF OUR VARIOUS DELIVERY
SYSTEM. I'M AT MORE AND YOU'RE
GETTING A VISUALLY TO ANNUAL A
CONSUMER EXPERIENCE AS SURVEYS-
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON BE A MEDICAL
LOSS RATIO. AS WELL AS A NUMBER
OF OTHER EVALUATIONS IN A BOTH
OF THE WAIVERS AROUND COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS. AS WELL AS THINGS LIKE
BE PROVIDING ACCESS IN
TRANSFORMING HEALTH OR WHAT WE
CALL THE PATH PROGRAM- D. AND C.
O. DS EVALUATION. AS G. P. P.
AND THAT I'M C. BATH PROGRAM ALL
THINGS WERE WE WILL HAVE TO DO
EVALUATIONS AND OF COURSE OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND AFTER
MANAGEMENT EVALUATIONS AND SO.
THESE ARE AT RISK RESOURCES ARTS
YOU ADD TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
NEW AGREEMENT BETWEEN US AND CMS
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU- FINANCE. INTERNAP
FROM FINANCE BIRD. OKAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL. OBVIOUSLY
CAL WAS A MAJOR- YOU POINTED OUT
- AND- I'VE ALWAYS AT THE
MIDNIGHT WELL IT'S BEEN A LITTLE
CONCERNED WHETHER WE HAVE ENOUGH
STAFF AT DH CS TO CARRY IT OUT
SO I GUESS HERE'S REQUEST. FOR
NINETY SEVEN POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE FORTY SO- SO WOULD
CERTAINLY WANT TO TRY TO BE SURE
YOU HAVE THE TEAM THAT YOU NEED
TO DO THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
EVALUATION- IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE. YOU WANNA SAY ABOUT THIS.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU LET'S MOVE
ON THE ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THEN
MANAGED CARE COMPLIANCE AND
OVERSIGHT PROGRAM. GREAT ALSO AS
YOU KNOW IDEAS YES IS CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF CONDUCTING A
STATEWIDE MANAGED CARE PLAN
PROCUREMENT- AS A PART OF THAT
EFFORT WE DEVELOPED THE A NEW
SINGLE CONTRACT AT THAT ALL
MANAGED CARE PLANS IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. I WILL BE
SUBJECT TO BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- IT ACTUALLY HAD
QUITE A FEW COMPREHENSIVE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND
ENHANCEMENTS OF OBLIGATIONS BUT
THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
WOULD HAVE TO MEET- WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT THEN MUST. REINFORCE
AS TO THE POSITIONS HERE REALLY
FOR EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
REQUESTED TO DO THAT MONITORING
OVERSIGHT OF THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS BASED ON THE NEW
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS. THE
DCS IS REQUESTING FOURTEEN A
PERMANENT POSITION THAT
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF THREE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS- IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE
NEW CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS- IN
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AFFECTED
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- THE
DEPARTMENT WILL NEED TO START
MUCH OF THIS ROBUST COMPLIANCE
IN THIS YEAR- ONCE WE DETERMINE
THE OUTCOME OF THE PROCUREMENT.
ALL MEDICARE PLANS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO START FILING REDNESS
AT POLICIES PROCEDURES OF
DOCUMENTATION- I WITH US TO
MEET. A NEW EXPERT ARE CONTRACT
TWENTY. AND IT'S A TWENTY. ALSO
THE RESOURCES ARE VERY MUCH
NEEDED BE AT AYE WRITE NEXT AND
THEN ON. WORK LOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS GREAT FINANCE.
LARA YEAH LET NO COMMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU AND REMIND ME- I KNOW
THAT THE THIS FIX AND JENNIFER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ONE- WHEN-
WHEN TWENTY EXPECTED NOW TO HAVE
THE CONTRACTS- I BELIEVE WE ARE
GOING TO BE AN AFTER THE
CONTRACT THE END OF SUMMER IS
WHERE I'M GONNA STAY ABOUT THE
SAME MONTH BUT I DON'T I REFER
FRANKLY IT'S AUGUST SEPTEMBER
TIME. ALRIGHT JUST- JUST
CHECKING ON THAT ALL RIGHT. OKAY
WELL AGAIN NEEDS TO BE SURE WE
HAVE TEAM AVAILABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF THE PROCUREMENT NINE NO
THAT'S AGAIN ANOTHER VERY
IMPORTANT AND- MAJOR. AT ACTION
BY. THE PART OF YOUR SERVICES
ALL RIGHT. OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE MANAGED
CARE. PROGRAM ANNUAL REPORT. YES
AT THE DHS IS REQUESTING TWENTY
ONE PERMANENT POSITIONS IN
EXPENDITURE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF A THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION A TO COMPLY WITH NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE
ANNOUNCED IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY A CMS AS A PART OF
THEIR NEW MONITORING SYSTEM-
OVER ALL MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
PLANS ACROSS. THE U. S. IT IS
KNOWN AS MAC PART OF INACTION
MAPR REALLY IS COLLECTING
INFORMATION IN A VARIETY OF
CATEGORIES SUCH AS INVOLVEMENT
OF FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE
ENCOUNTER DATA AS WELL AS
AVAILABILITY ACCESSIBILITY AND
NETWORK ADEQUACY- I MET PARK
CONSISTS OF EXTENSIVE NEW
MEASURES AND RECORDING ON BEHALF
THE DEPARTMENT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THESE RESOURCES
ARE I REQUEST THAT YOU MEET AND
COMPLY WITH THOSE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THAT YOU MAY HAVE
GREAT THANK YOU FINANCE. LARA
AYE AND COMING. OKAY THANK YOU-
SO AGAIN. LET'S COOPER THE
CREATE THE PRESENTATION CAN YOU
SPEAK TO PERHAPS- THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. IT IN TERMS OF
DATA COLLECTION FROM OUR MEDIC
HOW MANAGED CARE PLANS IS THIS
DATA WE'VE ALREADY. GOTTEN THAT
THE STATE THE REYES RECEIVED
FROM OUR MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND WE NOW NEED TO AT
LEAST I GUESS ON EVERY PACKAGE
IT BUT- PUT IT INTO THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM AND DO WHATEVER DATA
CLEANING WATER WE NEED TO DO OR
IS THIS A IS THIS ALSO INVOLVE
NEW DATA COLLECTION THAT WE
PREVIOUSLY HAD NEVER HAD. WE
NEVER ASKED FOR A MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF BOTH SO SOME OF IT
IS DATA THAT WE HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING WE WILL HAVE TO-
COLLECT IT MAYBE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY MOVING FORWARD- ACROSS OUR
VARIOUS DELIVERY SYSTEMS WILL
NEED TO MEET NEW- REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF HOW WE PACKAGE
IT AND SEND IT TO CMS AND THEN
SOME NEW. REQUIREMENTS FOR WE
WILL HAVE TO. ISSUE GUIDANCE TO
OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS UP AND
GATHER THAT INFORMATION FROM
THEM MOVING FORWARD- AND SO
WE'LL HAVE TO WRITE TECHNICAL
SPECIFICATIONS GUIDANCE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT DATA
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW WE NEED IT. I
THINK I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT OF
THIS IS ACROSS ALL OF OUR
MANAGED CARE AREAS THERE ARE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE. AND
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH YES YET
YES AND DENTAL AND SO THERE ARE
SOME GAPS ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE WE HAVEN'T
HISTORICALLY ASKED THAT FROM THE
COUNTIES THAT WILL BE NEW FOR
THEM AND SO- RELATIVELY
INTENSIVE RESOURCES THERE TO GET
NEW INFORMATION FROM COUNTIES
THAT THEY ARE. USED TO PROVIDING
AYE WHERE'S WE GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE FROM OUR CURRENT MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE PLANS FOR EXAMPLE.
ON THIS SO THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
LEVEL UP ACROSS ALL OF OUR-
DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN REGARDS TO
MEETING THIS YEAR I'M NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. YOU CAN
HEAR ME JUST GIVE A HIGH LEVEL
DESCRIPTION OF FOR SOME THE
DATA. SINCE I GUESS THE MAIN
CATEGORIES OF DATA THAT'S THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S NOW ASKING
THAT. HASN'T BEEN PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED DARLEY SUPPORTED US SO
THAT WE WEREN'T READY
COLLECTING. AND MAYBE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ALSO
PRESENTS. I WAS THE FEDS ARE
GOING TO COLLECTED FOR THEIR OWN
PURPOSES BUT THAT MIGHT ALSO
PRESENT FOR- THE STATE IN TERMS
OF OVERSIGHT. OR A QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. YEAH I MEAN. YOU TO
GET BACK YOU ONCE YOU DETAILS I
CAN GO ONE FOR. ARE TOPPING IT'S
A BREEDING IN A FEW DATA WE
ACTUALLY NOW COLLECT READINGS
APPEALS DAY BIRTHDAY- BIRDS. I
BECAUSE THAT A- OUR MEDICARE.
CARE PLANS. ARE IN THE WAY OF
THE- AND CAT OF. THEY AND
STANDARD IS. OF THE HAD A- ARE
NEW SO- I DO AGREE THAT WE WILL
HAVE MORE INFORMATION IN THE
FUTURE MANYOF THE THINGS
CHICKEN IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
SO. FUTURE FORWARD WE'LL HAVE
NEW DETAILS AND INFORMATION THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO SHARE THE NICE
CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL OF OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO ALLOW US
TO A LINE. I DID A RECORDING AND
HAVE SIMILAR. OF BENCHMARKS
ACROSS FIRED ARE TIRED DELIVERY
SYSTEM- IF THAT'S A HELPFUL
EXAMPLE FOR YOU IF THE TYPE OF
THINGS THAT THEY ARE REQUIRING
AND YOU WOULD BE REPORTING. OKAY
YES SIGN ANYTHING COULD BE THAT
YEAH AND THAT SINCE WE HAVE TO
COLLECTED ANYWAY AND- BUT ALSO-
YEAH. HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
REPORTS OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT WITH THIS NEW
DATA AND- ALSO PROVIDE PERHAPS
ALSO SOME FEEDBACK IF WE CAN
BREAK IT DOWN FOR COUNTY BY
COUNTY. GIVEN TO OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AS WELL- WHO ALSO ARE
YOU WORKING WITH THEY- DON'T
THEIR RESPECTIVE MANAGED CARE
PLANNER PLANS AND IT IT IT IT
DIDN'T AND MEDICARE ALSO- SO IN
ADDITION TO OF COURSE CERTAINLY.
YEAH COLLECTING THIS AND SEND IT
TO CMS'S THEY'RE REQUESTING TO
ALSO BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE SIMILAR
DATA. SHARE THAT SIMILAR DATA.
BROKEN DOWN APPROPRIATELY TO
VOTE FOR BOTH OUR STATE PURPOSES
FOR THE LEGISLATURE LOOK AT OF
COURSE AS FREE AGENCY AND
ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO FOR- OUR
LOCAL- NEEDS. AND IN CALIFORNIA-
SO THE DAY THEY CAN GET FEEDBACK
ON OUR PERFORMANCE. AND SO
FORTH. THE SECOND. I'LL
DEFINITELY TAKE THAT BACK I NOT
A FAMILIAR WITH THE- TEMPLATE
REPORTING. OF WORK TO HOW FLIES
WE'LL TAKE THAT BACK TO THE- AND
THE TEAM. OKAY YEAH YEAH SO WE
IT'S HOPEFULLY WE- THE COMPANY
THAT ANY YOU'RE A COLLECTED DATA
SO THE CAR. THANK WHERE'S IT
COMING FROM HIS WHAT YOU OF THE
PLAN THAT'S- WHICH COUNTY THAT
ADDRESS SO CAN TRY TO. THE MAKE
MAXIMUM OF THE DAY. AS WELL-
SINCE WE'RE A COLLECTING THE DAY
SO JUST SURE WE HAVE ALUM THAT
WE ALSO DO OUR OWN A- HERE STATE
AND ALSO. SOME FEEDBACK TO-
COUNTIES WELL IN TERMS OF THEIR
PERFORMANCE- THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. OKAY ALL. RIGHT-
ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS ITEM. AND
NOTHING ELSE ON THE FIRING ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER TEN. COMPLIANCE I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO LAURIE- A WALKER
WHO WILL DO THE REST OF THE
ITEMS FROM GATES YES. HI HI GOOD
MORNING THANKS ANYTHING. AFTER
THE OFFICE OF COMPLIANCE. THE
ABSENCE REQUESTING TWELVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS OF
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. TO COMPLETE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE NEWLY
CREATED OFFICE OF COMPLIANCE AND
STRENGTHEN INFLUENCE WALKING OFF
ON SIMPLE HOW COME. THE
FOLLOWING AREAS ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF OUR OFFICE
OF COMPLIANCE AND INCLUDE.
COMPLIANCE MONITORING AND
FEDERAL REPORTING ACROSS THE
FRONT NAY INVOLVING FEDERAL AND
STATE. ENGAGEMENTS ACROSS
MULTIPLE FAKE PLANTS ALREADY
FEDERAL WAIVERS. FEDERAL
ANYTHING MICHIGAN FROM VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO FEDERAL
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. IT INCLUDES
INTERNAL AUDITING ESPECIALLY IN
THE THING. AND APPRISE RISK
MANAGEMENT SERVICES SUCH OF
ASSURANCE AND ADVISORY SERVICES
ACROSS AN APARTMENT. AND FINALLY
TO AFFECT THEM OPERATIONAL
RISING AND SUSTAINING OVERALL
ENTERPRISE. GOVERNANCE I THINK.
AND THE LIKELIHOOD MY FREAKING
HAVE DANCE AND QUESTION THANK
YOU FINANCE. WELCOMING THE PART
FINANCE OF THE OUT OKAY SO SIT-
SO TO CLARIFY A- SO WE'VE JUST
TALKED ABOUT BE C. P. FOR
NATIONALS TO DO OVERSIGHT. DATA
CLASS ARE SO DOES ALL COMPLY IN
THIS- HE JUST BECAUSE- WHERE
THERE'S OTHER YOU KNOW THE BIG
WILD BIG DEPARTMENT THAT I WAS
THE L. ONE OF THE MAJOR ROLES
APARTMENT TO SURE THAT WORK- YOU
KNOW FOLLOWING OUR FEDERAL RULES
BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL STATE
PARTNERSHIP SO- SO HOW THIS
OFFICE VERY SOON YOU'RE NOT
DOING ALL THE COMPLAINTS WORK
YOURSELF ACTUALLY THERE'S A LOT
OF DATA COLLECTION THAT CENTER
HAPPENING WE JUST TALKED ABOUT-
YEAH BCPS. TO LOOK AT NOW
COLLECTING DATA THAT THE CMS
WATER FELL GOVERNMENT ONCE RIGHT
SO WHERE DOES OFFICE COMPLIANCE.
FIT IN ALL THIS ARE YOU SORT OF
LIKE AN AUDITING ENTITY BE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE. DOING THEIR
JOBS SO THAT WE CAN TELL CMS
WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING ARE
THAT IT'S OKAY TO SPEAK A LITTLE
MORE. ELABORATE LOW MORE ON THE
ROLE THE OFFICE COMPLIANCE. SURE
I CAN GIVE YOU A LITTLE MORE
DETAILS OUR OFFICE OF COMPLIANCE
IS ESSENTIALLY DOING. OUR
INTERNAL COMPLIANCE MONITORING
SO MAKING SURE DH YEAH. IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE WAY FOR
REQUIRED WE'RE MEETING WAIVER
REQUIREMENTS AND TIMELINE FOR
MEETING. THEIR REQUIREMENTS AND
FAMILY. IT'S ALSO ASSISTING WITH
INTERNAL AUDITING OF OUR OWN
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE RULES WE
ESTABLISHED. THROWING POLICIES
MITIGATING RISK. I WAS DOING ARE
ARE USUALLY HAVE FARMS OKAY SEE
LIKE AN INTERNAL- YOU'RE LIKE AN
INTERNAL AUDIT. EXACTLY OKAY
YEAH. ALL RIGHT THAT OKAY THEN
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE ASKING FOR
AUDITORS OKAY SO OKAY- ALL RIGHT
SO THAT'S HELPFUL TO KNOW
ALREADY CLARIFIED OKAY- ANYTHING
ELSE ANDERSON. ALL RIGHT THAT'S
- NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN- THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
IN. SYSTEM MODERN. OF NOTHING
LIKE IT SYSTEMS ALL RIGHT. OKAY
GREAT I'LL BE BACK WHEN I NEED
FOR FIVE BERMAN POSITION WHEN
TURN FUNDING FOR RESOURCES OUT
OF NINETEEN SEVEN DOLLARS FOR A
TOTAL. TWENTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
THE FISCAL YEAR THE U. S.
RECEIVED NINETY SEVEN HERE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
MODERNIZATION OF OUR SYSTEM
WHICH ARE CRITICAL FOR
ADMINISTERING THE FINAL PROGRAM.
THE RESEARCH REQUEST SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES THE FOLLOWING
APPROVED PROJECT THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AFTER HE CAN YOU WORK
TO DEVELOP THE OVERALL. DRIVE
MODERNIZATION STRATEGY LIVE FROM
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
INTO SOLUTION DESIGN DEVELOPMENT
DEPLOYMENT FOR THE NEW
CALIFORNIA AUTOMATED RECOVERY
MANAGEMENT SOLUTION AND CONTINUE
WORKING THROUGH THE PROJECT
APPROVAL BY CYCLE FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH MODERNIZATION
PROJECT. AND WORK EFFECTIVELY ON
STAGE THREE WHICH IS PROJECT
PROCUREMENT. TO KEEP PACE WITH
SERVICE DELIVERY CHANGES FROM
THREE FOR SERVICE AD MANAGED
CARE AND TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
WILL RESTART THE QUESTION FOR
YOU. THE CASF CHANCE OF
MODERNIZATION APPROACH FROM
FOCUSING ON INDIVIDUAL
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS ARE PROJECTS.
FOCUSING ON THE ENTIRE MEDICAID
ENTERPRISE. AND OVER PLAN TO
INCREMENTALLY MODERNIZE OUR
SYSTEM THE SYSTEM NECESSARY TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. THIS IS
A SIGNIFICANT CONTACT AFRICAN WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS ON THE
SUBJECT THE ROBUST LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. VIA QUARTERLY
BRIEFING IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET.
WILL HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FINANCE.
INTERCAPITAL BERMAN ON FURTHER.
OKAY AND I THINK ELIO HAS
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THE ONE
ALL RIGHT L. L. GOOD MORNING
METZGER L. A. I WE HAVE NOTICED
. CAN WITH PROPOSAL BUT RECKONED
APPROVE WITH PROVISIONAL BUDGET
BILLING. THERE WERE THAT A TO
SAY IT'S A MY- STRATEGY FOR THIS
EFFORT VILLAGE- THE MES. EFFORT
WILL UPDATE AND REPLACE MANY OF
THE I. T. SYSTEMS THAT SUPPORT
THE STATE'S MEDICAID PROGRAM. IN
THE INITIAL STRATEGY WILL
OUTLINE THE GOALS OUTCOMES
TARGETS FOR THIS EFFORT DECIDE
THE ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR THE EFFORT AS WELL AS START
TO EXPLAIN HOW ALL OF THE
PROJECTS WITHIN THIS EFFORT WILL
BE DEVELOPED AND IMPLEMENTED.
CONSISTENT MEETING THIS
DOCUMENTATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HELP TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
EFFORT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
MITIGATED. AND HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE TO COMPLETE THIS EFFORT AS
WELL AS AT WHAT COST- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERS THIS
LANGUAGE TO BE POTENTIALLY
DUPLICATIVE OF THE CURRENT
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES QUARTERLY MEETINGS- BUT
WE THINK MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE
TO SPECIFY THAT THE STRATEGY
DOCUMENTATION BE DELIVERED. BY
THE END OF THE BUDGET YEAR WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLARIFY- THIS
EFFORT AS IT MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU. HI THANK YOU AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT RECOMMENDATION
AND AN AGREEMENT WITH THAT- CAN.
SO CAN YOU- F. DTS SECOND. HE
SPEAK TO. A POLICY WE HADN'T
NUMEROUS EXAMPLES OF OUTDATED
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE FAILED US-
DURING CRITICAL MOMENTS- AND-
FINDING OUT THAT WE HAVE LEGACY
SYSTEMS THERE EVEN WRITTEN AND-
YOU KNOW PROGRAMMING LANGUAGES
THAT- NO ONE LEARNS ANYMORE
WE'RE TRYING TO POINT RETIREES.
WHO WHO KNOW KOBOL ANOTHER TYPED
LANGUAGES WHICH I THINK IF I
SHARED THEM WITH THE- PEOPLE WHO
ARE MUCH YOUNGER AND I THINK
WHAT'S THAT- SO CAN MAYBE SPEAK.
WHAT'S THAT STATE OF THE OF SOME
OF THESE MEDICAL SYSTEMS ARE WE
ARE WE IN THAT SITUATION WITH
MEDIC CAL- AND FOR SOME OF OUR
SYSTEMS LEGACY SYSTEMS AND THEN
ALSO IN TERMS OF THE
MODERNIZATION APPROACH- YOU KNOW
HOW. CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE WORKING WITH-
FOR EXAMPLE WELL I MEAN I THINK
IN THE- CITY ITSELF IS A VERY
LARGE DEPARTMENT BUT WORKING
WITH THAT. THE THE PART OF
TECHNOLOGY AND WITH THE- WITH
THE- I GUESS SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
AND- THE PART HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ON THESE PROJECTS. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION I'M
NOT GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER CHRIS
RETURN TO GIVE YOU MORE
DETAILED. FONG THANK YOU. HEY
CHRIS RESEND DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER AND- SO
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT THE STATE
OF THE SYSTEMS- ABSOLUTELY- D.
ACS HAS. HUNDREDS OF BUSINESS
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE PART OF
HOW WE DO BUSINESS EVERY DAY AND
SOME OF THOSE SYSTEMS GO BACK
FORTY PLUS YEARS IN TERMS OF
HAVING BEEN BUILT. AND THEY'RE
STILL WRITTEN IN THE SAME
LANGUAGES THAT THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY WRITTEN IN SOME OF
ITS COBALT- IN FACT WE JUST HAD
THE FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
MEDS SYSTEM ONE OF OUR CRITICAL
STATE SYSTEM SO- YES WE'RE IN
THAT BOAT- NOW JUST BECAUSE IT
IS A SYSTEM. THAT IS WRITTEN IN
AN OLDER LANGUAGE DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT IT IS NECESSARILY OF
SIGNIFICANT RISK- I'LL JUST USE
MEDS AS AN EXAMPLE IT HAS
CONTINUED TO OPERATE- OUR STATE
STAFF TO SUPPORT THE SYSTEM DO A
GREAT JOB- BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE IS A RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS. AND HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO RUN THOSE
OLDER SYSTEMS. I WILL SAY I'VE
HEARD OF- RECENTLY- AND WELL
MAYBE IN RECENT YEARS ABOUT
KOBOL. BEING TALKED ONCE AGAIN
IN COLLEGES. HOWEVER I DON'T
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BASE OUR
FUTURE ON ON THAT LAST THAT
SITUATION I THINK IT'S MORE
BECAUSE IT CAN BE LUCRATIVE
BECAUSE QUITE A FEW
ORGANIZATIONS ACTUALLY HAVE-
OLDER SYSTEM- IS THAT GOOD FOR
YOUR FIRST QUESTION YEAH YOU
KNOW THAT THAT THAT'S HELPFUL-
SO I GUESS- JUST LOG OUT SWITCH
FROM COBALT TO FORTRAN AND NOW
EVERYONE'S GOING LIKE WHAT ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT I THINK WE'RE
REALLY DATING OURSELVES- YES. IN
AN HOUR APPROACH FOR THE NEW
SYSTEMS IS ABSOLUTELY MODERN-
BOTH IN TERMS OF- OUR APPROACH
TO BUILDING THOSE SYSTEMS BUT
ALSO THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT WE USED TO BUILD
THEM- THE SECOND QUESTION IN
TERMS OF THE CURRENT- WORK
HAPPENING TO BUILD OUT THE
APPROACH IN THE STRATEGY FOR HOW
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
MODERNIZING ALL OF THESE
SYSTEMS- YES WE WORK- CLOSELY.
PARTICULARLY WITH- DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN FACT WE HAVE
REGULAR WORK AT IT THAT'S
OCCURRING- FOR US THIS WORK TO
PLAN OUT THAT STRATEGY IS NOT AT
A PROJECT LEVEL- IT'S AT A
HIGHER LEVEL. AND WE HAVE
REGULAR INTERACTIONS AND
INVOLVEMENTS WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- THEY ARE INCLUDED IN
THE REGULAR UPDATES THAT WE DO-
SOMETIMES ON A WEEKLY BASIS
SOMETIMES- EVERY OTHER WEEK. AND
WE REGULARLY INVITE THEM TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND- COMMENTS
ON WHERE WE'RE AT WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON AT THE TIME- BUT
OVERALL THE APPROACH AND
STRATEGY. IN ADDITION- WE HAVE
PROVIDED THEM- IN ESSENCE- WORK
PRODUCTS OR DELIVERABLES OUT OF-
THIS EFFORT AND- SO THAT THEY
HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
BROAD MORE BROADLY WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION AND HOW- FEEDBACK
PROVIDED TO US THAT WE CAN TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT AS WE CONTINUE TO
REFINE. THE OVERALL APPROACH IN
THIS IS THIS WILL BE NOT JUST AS
WE WORK ON THE APPROACH AND
STRATEGY BUT IT'S AN ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP.
THAT WE HAVE WITH THEM SO IT
WILL CONTINUE AS WE GO FORWARD
ON THIS- VERY BROAD AND- EVERY
COMPLEX AND LARGE EFFORTS. IN
ADDITION FROM A COW HHS AGENCIES
STANDPOINT- WE HAVE SOME VERY
SIMILAR RELATIONSHIP IMPACT- SO
THE OFFICE OF THE AGENCY
INFORMATION OFFICER IS INVOLVED
IN THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING-
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT- MAYBE MORE
HANDS ON IN CLOSER TO THE WORK-
AND- WORKING WITH US TO DEVELOP.
WHAT WE HAVE- BUT THEY ALSO
PROVIDE REGULAR FEEDBACK
COMMENTS AND HELP US TO CONTINUE
TO SHAPE WHERE WE'RE GOING- IT'S
NOT THE OFFICE OF SYSTEM
INTEGRATION THE WE WORK. CLOSELY
WITH THEM ON VARIOUS EFFORTS
THAT IT THAT ARE TIED TO ALL OF
THIS- AND MEETING THE OVERALL.
MATT OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL GUESS I
GUESS THIS YOU OBSERVE IN AGAIN
BRIGITTE L. A. AS
RECOMMENDATIONS- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- IT PROJECTS- WHEN
THEY GO WELL WE DON'T HEAR MUCH
ABOUT HIM- WHEN THEY GO BADLY-
THEY MAKE THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
NEWS- THEY'RE USUALLY FAIRLY
EXPENSIVE SO THERE'S A
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENT IN STATE
RESOURCES SO I RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS JUST PROBABLY JUST SOME
AND YOU KNOW THE TWENTY MILLION
WERE NOT TALK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. PLANNING AND SO FORTH AND
FIGURING THINGS OUT NOT
ACTUALLY- BUT I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS THAT- WHEN IT COMES TO
I. T. AND YOU KNOW YOU TO TALK
ABOUT LEGACY SYSTEMS AND SO
FORTH AND- AND I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW THE ISSUE ISN'T SO MUCH A
LEGACY SYSTEM CAN'T WORK- IS
THAT- IS THAT AS YOU POINT OUT
AND- THANK OVER TIME- IT MAY
BECOME MORE MORE CHALLENGING. TO
FOR IN TERMS OF HOW IT LINKS TO
OTHER SYSTEMS HAVING FINING THE
PERSONNEL TO MAINTAIN IT TOO IF
IN CASE SOMETHING DOES HAPPEN.
TO MAKE MODIFICATIONS AND SO
FORTH AND SO THE EVENTUALLY
GONNA NEED A TRANSITION PLAN- TO
MORE MMHM THE L. BUT DATED
SYSTEM THAT IS GOING TO BE THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE MORE MANAGEABLE
SO WHAT. ENOUGH URGENT THE
<c.magenta>OMENT IF YOU KNOW THE LONGER WE</c>
WAIT THE GREATER CHALLENGE BE
THAT- I THINK IF THE APPROACH IN
THE FUTURE IS NOT SO MUCH WHY
CALL LIKE YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THAT
WE NEED ONE SYSTEM OR ONE VERY
LARGE SYSTEM TO THEN TAKE CARE
OF ALL OF THAT ACCOUNT ALL
RIGHT. IT'S ACTUALLY HOW DO WE
BUILD MODULAR SYSTEMS RIGHT SO
THAT THERE'S- SO NOT FOR EXAMPLE
TRAPPED WITH THE- THE WITH ONLY
HAVING. TWO OR THREE VENDORS WHO
CAN HANDLE HUGE SYSTEM RIGHT
IT'S AT THE HEART OF THE
BUILDINGS IN THE MODULAR WAY
THAT CAN. AND FRANKLY OF ALL
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT ABOUT BUILDING
A SYSTEM FOR- YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
FIVE YEARS OR WHATEVER THAT WILL
TAKE CARE OF EVERYTHING AND THEN
WE NEED TO REDO IT AGAIN AND
THIRTY YEARS AFTER THAT IT'S
MORE LIKE IT HOW HOW DO WE BUILD
SYSTEMS THAT CAN INVOLVE. THIS
TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES RATE SO- AND
OUTLINING THAT APPROACH I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT SO
HOW DO WE TAKE WHAT WE HAVE NOW
HOW DO WE EVOLVE THAT INTO THE
FUTURE. HOW DO WE BILL HOW YOU
BUILD OUT A- AND I. T-
ESSENTIALLY ECOSYSTEM. THAT CAN
SERVE THE NEEDS A MEDIC CAL EVEN
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO MEDIKAL
ITSELF. AND THAT- AND THAT I. T.
UP NO WE FOR EXAMPLE. WE'VE
HEARD THAT ONE REASONS THAT BEEN
GIVEN FOR FREE FOR WHY WE HAVE
TO DELAY AND TRYING TO ROLL.
UNDOCUMENTED DAHLE SEWER NOT SEE
. AND I USED. IS THE I. T. SAYS
. MAY NOT BE ABLE TO UP SOME GOT
THREE. VILLAGE WELL WE NEED TO
HAVE SYSTEMS THAT CAN MOVE AT
THE SPEED OF WHICH WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE POLICY- AND THEN OF
COURSE YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T WITH
CMS AND SO THERE'S- NO POLICY
THAT CHANGES RIGHT AND- WHETHER.
IT'S GOOD THINGS- LIKE CAL AIM
AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND
SOMETIMES THERE'S OTHER
REQUIREMENTS AND WE JUST
ACTUALLY HAD A VCP ABOUT YOU
KNOW INCREASING REQUIREMENTS
FOR. TERRA SO- FOR- FOR
EVALUATION AND ACCOUNTABILITY
RIGHT SO- SO WHAT. WOULD BE
HELPFUL IS TO BE ABLE TO SEE AND
AGAIN GOING BACK TO WHAT THEY
LOW RECOMMENDATION IS THAT. SO
WHAT IS THAT. SIR THAT PATH TO
BUILDING THAT KIND OF AN IT
SYSTEM FOR MEDICARE WHICH OF
COURSE ALSO S. INTEGRATE. AND
CONNECT WITH ALL THE OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICE AND- OTHER HEALTH
CARE RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A- A YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A- YOU KNOW BETWEEN A-
PEAK. PAYER DATABASE TO ON THE
HEALTH SIDE TO HAVING A- YEAH-
THAT THE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE AND THEN ON THE SOCIAL
SERVICE SIDE OF COURSE WITH
MEDICARE HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW
THAT CONNECT FOR ALL THE
ELIGIBILITY STUFF THAT HAPPENS
NOT ONLY FOR MEDICARE- BUT FOR
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES AND SO
FORTH. SO CERTAINLY MEDICAL
SYSTEMS. THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE
COVERED CALIFORNIA AS WELL. SO
YOU SET THE SET A LITTLE BIT OF
A NEXUS OF. HAVING INTERFACE
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY HELP IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF SERVICE NOT ONLY
FOR MEDIC CAL ITSELF- BUT ALSO
FOR OTHER SERVICES THAT EIGHT
THAT THE DEDICATION REYES MAY
RECEIVE. AS WELL SO-IT SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT SOUNDS OVERLY
AMBITIOUS BUT- I THINK THAT'S-
WOULD LIKE TO GET SOME FEEDBACK
AS TO HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT
AND WHAT THE PLANS MIGHT BE.
TEMPTED TO ACHIEVE THOSE THINGS.
SO DO YOU HAVE ANY. THAT LOOTING
AND WHAT ELSE IS IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE SECRETLY ATTENDING OUR
MEETING SENATOR. HE WHAT YOU
EVERYTHING THAT YOU JUST RAN
THROUGH IS ACTUALLY RIGHT IN
LINE WITH OUR WE ARE DEVELOPING
SYSTEMS NEW SYSTEMS AT DH CS- WE
ARE THERE IS A REQUIREMENT- IN
ESSENCE FROM CMS. THAT WE BUILD
MODULAR BUT THAT'S IT THE NATURE
AND THE CORE OF OUR WE ARE
BUILDING SYSTEM THESE DAYS THESE
DAYS FOR GOOD REASON ALL
EVERYTHING THAT YOU MENTIONED
NOT JUST BECAUSE CMS THINGS
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
AND SO. YEAH EVERYTHING THAT YOU
MENTIONED IS THE APPROACH THAT
WE'RE USING WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THIS APPROACH THROUGH THE
FEDERAL DRAWING REPORTING
PROJECT- THAT'S COMING TO A
CLOSE THIS JUNE. WE TAKE NOT
ONLY IN APPROACH TO DELIVERING-
THE SYSTEMS AND MODULES OR
COMPONENTS OR SERVICES-
WHICHEVER WORDS WE WANT TO USE
BUT WE ALSO TAKE AN APPROACH TO
DELIVER EARLY AND OFTEN. WE WANT
TO GET THE SYSTEMS AND THE
FUNCTIONALITY AND OUR PROGRAMS
HANDS AVAILABLE FOR YOU SO THAT
WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
BUILDING THOSE SYSTEMS THAT'S
THE AGILE APPROACH THAT THAT
LAURIE MENTIONED WHEN SHE WAS
SPEAKING- AND- AND WE DO THAT SO
THAT WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB AND
EVOLVE IT TO YOUR POINT- WITHOUT
A DOUBT. WE TAKE EVERY APPROACH
THAT WE CAN AND WE'RE BUILDING
THE SYSTEMS TO MAKE THEM ABLE TO
BE MORE FLEXIBLE FOR THE FUTURE-
SO WERE WERE RIGHT IN LINE WITH.
WHAT YOU SAID THAT IS PART OF
OUR CURRENT APPROACH AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF OUR
APPROACH GOING FORWARD. OKAY
EVERY SHEET THAT- I WAS HAVE NOT
BEEN SECRETLY ATTENDING YOUR
MEETINGS- I GUESS. TWELVE TWELVE
YEAH. A CERTAIN SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
WELL AT LEAST ME SOME INSIGHT-
YES- BUT IT IT AGAIN IT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO HAVE
SOME REPORTING BACK LANGUAGE- AS
THE L. A. O. SUGGESTED SO THAT.
YOU CAN AT PRESENT- TO US AT
LEAST WHAT THE LATEST THINKING
IS AND WHAT. IT AND ALSO WHAT.
IS WORK ON IT AND I'M SURE
THERE'S GOING TO BE ADDITIONAL
ASKS AND LARGER ASKS FOR IT
MODERNIZATION. THAT THAT WILL
HELP- I GUESS- CONTINUE TO BUILD
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND THAT- AS WE
MAKE- CENTURIES VERY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND- IT
INFRASTRUCTURE- TWO TWO AGAIN
THE THAT THE OUTCOME OF
IMPROVING. THE QUALITY OF
SERVICE AND- ANDERSON FISSION
SEE UP IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM SO
AGAIN PRECIADO- BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME CELLS MUCH AS I
MAY SEEM LIKE I'M SECRETLY
ATTENDING MEETINGS ACTUALLY NEED
SOME REPORTS BACK. I KNOW WHAT
YOU REALLY GOING ON AND STUFF.
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW SENATOR-
WE'VE PROVIDED QUARTERLY
BRIEFING TODAY- AND WE IN THAT
BRIEF SCENE WE PROVIDE AN
OVERALL VIEW OF THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON SO WHILE WE
HAVEN'T SORT OF DELIVERED THE
OFFICIAL MUSIC CAN ROAD MAP AND-
WHERE WE'RE GOING. NUMBER WHICH
WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE LIKE THE
SYSTEMS BASED UPON NEEDS WE
PROVIDE THAT MU IN THE BRIEFINGS
TODAY AND WE WILL AND WE INTEND
TO- BE PROVIDED IT- AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
SUFFICIENT LANGUAGE IN PLACE ARE
ON THAT- PLUS IT'S JUST PART OF
OUR APPROACH- AND THEN THE- PART
THAT I. JUST WANT TO BE. ON IN
TERMS OF THE DOLLARS IN THE B.
C. IS. TO THREE FOUR OF THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THIS ONE ARE
ACTUALLY ABOUT DELIVERING- THAT
SYSTEMS AND PRODUCT. IT'S A
SMALL IT'S THE SMALLER PORTION
THAT'S RELATED TO THE ACTUAL
STRATEGY AND DELIVERY AND THAT'S
A PART OF IT RIGHT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE DELIVERING NOT
JUST WORKING ON. THE ROAD CHEN
STRATEGY AND SUCH OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANYTHING ELSE ON ITEM
ELEVEN. ANY FINAL CUT X. P. L.
A. O. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
NO NO INTERESTING OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
ON THE ISSUE TWELVE IN DATA
ANALYTICS MANAGEMENT SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU. THE EXPANSIVE
REQUESTING THIRTEEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND FUNDING FOR
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES FOR AN
EXPENDITURE FORTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. WITH A
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND. YES
HAVE BEEN CONSOLIDATING DATA
ANALYTICS MANAGEMENT
PROVISIONING REPORTING
ACTIVITIES IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
DATA LITERACY AND DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT BUSINESS PROGRAMS AND
EVENTS. THE PROPOSAL SUPPORT
EXPERIENCE DEPARTMENTAL PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE KNOWN GAPS IN DATA
LITERACY IN ANALYTICS AND
INCREASES CAPACITY RELATED TO
DATA TRANSPARENCY IN
COORDINATION. DATA VISUALIZATION
REPORTING AND ANALYTICAL SUPPORT
IN DATA ANALYTICS AND MANAGEMENT
WE'RE HAPPY TO DEFINITIONAL
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU AYE
FINANCE. OF FORMER IRVINE- THE
HOBBIT OKAY HELLO. BECAUSE MORE
THAN L. A. NO OF THIS ALL RIGHT
OKAY AND THE SO CERTAIN- THANK
YOU AGAIN APPRECIATE
PRESENTATION I HAVING US FOR
LIKE THE PART HEALTHCARE SO-
DATA ANALYTICS AND VISUALIZATION
OF THINGS WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HELP SUPPORT THE-
STAFF AND HELPING THEM- YOU KNOW
MAKE MAKE GOOD DECISIONS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE SYSTEM. YOU YOU DID MENTION
THERE UP THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS
IN THE EIGHTY S. THAT HAS A
PARTICULAR NEED FOR THESE
SERVICES THAT THIS- PROPOSAL
WOULD HELP- CAN YOU BE MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT- WHICH AREAS ARE
IN AND DHS- WOULD PARTICULARLY
BENEFIT FROM- THAT FROM FROM
FROM THIS. NEW STAFF IN THE WORK
THAT THEY WOULD BE DOING. YES I
BELIEVE WE HAVE BILL HEINRICH.
ON THE PHONE THAT CAN AFFECT
OKAY TRANSPARENCY GAP ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. SURE THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION DOCTOR PANEL- WE DO OR
SEEN INCREASE AND- THE WAY
MEDIKAL IS RUN BEING MORE DATA
DRIVEN YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT JUST
PAYING CLAIMS ANYMORE. AND THE
NEED FOR DATA EXTERNALLY AND
INTERNALLY TO HELP US RUN THE
PROGRAM HAS GROWN AND- AND WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW- WHEN WE LOOK
AT TRENDS IN HEALTHCARE. SO
SPECIFIC AREAS ARE PROGRAM AREAS
CERTAINLY IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
IN PROVIDER AREAS PROVIDER
ADEQUACY. THOSE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES WHERE- THE DATA NEED
HAS GROWN. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT- SO WHAT IT IS I GUESS A
COUPLE OBSERVATIONS THE FIRST OF
COURSE- NICKNAMES I THINK DHS'S
A DATA RICH AGENCY THERE'S A LOT
OF DATA COLLECTED BY DATA ISN'T
VERY HELPFUL MUCH YOU COULD TURN
INTO INFORMATION RIGHT SO
SOMETHING COULD ACT ON. SO YOU
CAN HAVE A WHOLE HUGE POOL OF
DATA THAT SOMEONE ISN'T DOING
ANALYTICS ISN'T ABLE TO PROCESS
IT IT DOESN'T BECOME VERY
HELPFUL FOR DECISION MAKING SO
THAT'S- SO CERTAINLY AGREE THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THE KIND OF
FUNCTIONS ARE DESCRIBED IN THIS
PROPOSAL. THE I THINK YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE AREAS THAT. CAN BE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IS FOR
EXAMPLE BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
LIKE- YOU KNOW RISK POOLS OF AND
HAVE IS WE'RE DOING TO
PROCUREMENT SO WHAT IT WHAT
EXACTLY IS THE ACTUAL. DENNIS
LYING- YOU KNOW- THE RISK. AND
VARIABILITY THAT OF- IN TERMS
OF- NEED- THAT- ARE VARIOUS
PLANS AND SO FORTH THEY'RE
HAVING CONTRACTS WITH THAT
THEY'RE FACING AND SO FORTH
ENSURED THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
THE CARE THEY NEED- SO WELL
THEY'RE BEARING RISK WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF RISK
THEY ACTUAR BEARING SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE BETTER CONTRACTS- AND
ALSO. I THINK RISK ADJUSTMENTS
CAN BE CRITICAL TO BE SURE WE
ALLOCATE- MEDICARE FUNDS- YOU
KNOW THE MOST APPROPRIATELY AS
WE HAVE IS BASICALLY OPERATING
THROUGH OF A YOU KNOW A LARGE
NUMBER OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS- AND THEN ALSO TO DRESS
EQUITY AS WELL- SO. THAT'S WHICH
SOMETIMES ISN'T ALWAYS CAPTURED
BY A RISK ADJUSTMENT SO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE EQUITY
MEASURES AS WELL SO THAT POINT
OUT THAT SOMEONE'S DIABETES.
LIVES IN ONE NEIGHBORHOOD MAY
NEED FEWER RESOURCES ON DIABETES
ANOTHER ONE JUST BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND THAT BECOMES AN
EQUITY ISSUE AS WELL- SO
HOPEFULLY- THE. THIS- THE YOU
CAN HELP OUT AND HELP SUPPORT-
THE MEMBERS OF STAFF WHO ARE
DOING THIS KIND OF WORK- THAT IS
WELL SO. IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
SOUND THAT THAT IT. IS THAT.
WITH ONE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT THIS GROUP WOULD BE DOING
OUR MY OFF BRACE ON THAT. YOU'RE
RIGHT ON- EQUITY AND- AND THOSE
OTHER ISSUES ARE HIGH PRIORITIES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. IN USING
DATA TO IDENTIFY RISKS AND- NO
BETTER USE OF OUR- STATE FUNDS.
IS- IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ON THIS ONE. OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON THEN FOUND ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN AND DROP A BILITY
FEDERAL IMPLEMENTATION. RIGHT
THANK YOU THINK YES OF
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR SIX I
HAVE BEEN FIXING PERMANENT
POSITION THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITION LEVEL INTO TWELFTH
POSITION AND ONE YEAR LIMITED
TERM RESOURCES EQUIVALENT TO
EIGHT PHYSICIANS AND
REAPPROPRIATION CONTRACT
FUNDING. FOR A TOTAL OF FROM OUR
TERRITORY REQUEST THE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT AND
ADDITIONALLY PLANNED FOR THE
INTER OPERABILITY IN PATIENT
ACCESS RULE REQUIRED BY THE LAND
BY. FEDERAL CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID. YES RECEIVED
PLANNING RE. DURING OUR BY YEAR
. THE PROPOSAL.
CHECK THE QUOTE THE THIRTEENTH
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES INTER
OPERABILITY EXPERTISE IN
COORDINATION FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION. AND FURTHER
PLANNING FOR TECHNICAL
IMPLEMENTATION CAN BE REQUIRED
WITH THE GRAPHICS OF THE YEAH.
WITH ALL THE CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
DEPARTMENT COMPLIANCE WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY THREE.
I WHICH OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY DATA
EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK FIREMAN. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. CORRECT
THANK YOU AYE FINANCE. HI
MADISON SHEFFIELD NOTHING TO ADD
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- L. A.
L. MOREOVER THE LA- NO CONCERNS
ALL RIGHT OKAY. ALL RIGHT- YEAH
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION CERTAINLY IT'S-
VERY IMPORTANT WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE AS WELL- AND- YEAH I
THINK WE TOUCHED ON IT A LITTLE
EARLIER AND ON THE PREVIOUS ONES
ABOUT THAT WHERE DHS THAT'S A
NEXUS WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OTHER THINGS INCLUDING OF COURSE
ARE- VERY- SUTTER HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES IN. AND
INTERRUPTED UP. IN OPERABILITY
IS GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT SO-
OKAY- ANY OTHER COMMENTS. OKAY
WELL THANK YOU- THANK
REPRESENTATION I THINK THAT
COMPLETES ALL OF THE ITEMS
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT SO- WITH THAT-
WILL NOW MOVE- CAN WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THAT THE PART OF YOUR SERVICE
AREA PRESENTATION ANOTHER MOVE
ON TO- PUBLIC COMMENT- SINCE I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. SO WILL
BEGIN HERE IN THIS ROOM SO JUST
THE GROUND RULES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- BASICALLY- IF YOU WISH
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS- YEAH AND
THE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON THE
ITEMS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
TODAY- YOU WILL OF GIVE EACH
PRESENTER- ONE MINUTE. IF YOU
HAVE HAPPEN TO HAVE SOMETHING
LONGER YOU WANT TO PRESENT TO US
PLEASE SEND IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WRITING- SO- SO
IF YOU CAN JUST SORT OF HIT THE
HIGHLIGHTS- BUT BASICALLY I'M
GONNA GIVE EACH. PERSON A MINUTE
TO PRESENT SO PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF TELL ME WHAT IF YOUR
ORDER REPRESENT ORGANIZATION AND
THEN OF COURSE IT IF YOU CAN
IDENTIFY WHICH ISSUE ITEMS THAT
YOU ARE TYPICALLY COMMENT ON
THAT ALSO BE HELPFUL AS WELL.
AND THEN MAKE YOUR COMMENT AND
THEN OF COURSE IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO CAPTURE ALL AND YOUR ONE
MINUTE TO PLEASE ALSO FOLLOW UP
WITH A- AND YOU'VE CERTAIN
TESTIMONY AS WELL SO. BUT APPLE
BEGIN HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED A PLEASE COME UP TO LIKE
TWELVE WELCOME WELCOME HELLO.
CENTER PAN. BECAUSE IT TEARS ON
BEHALF OF THE- GOVERNOR
CONSORTIUM OF A- PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL- FIRST JUST LIKE TO
MENTION THAT WE DO SUPPORT THE
ONE TIME TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST- PRESENTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY- BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
NUMBER FOR A WE'RE OPPOSE OF THE
DAC S. D. H. C. S. PROPOSAL 62%
INCREASE IN FEES- GIVEN THE
NONPROFIT NATURE OF OUR
FACILITIES- AND COST SAVINGS
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO OTHER
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA THE FEE
STRUCTURE. WILL DAMPEN HAVE A
DAMPENING EFFECT ON CAPACITY-
THESE FEES RESTRICT ACCESS IN
PARTICULAR TO AREAS RURAL AREAS
WHERE THE SOCIAL MODEL PROGRAMS
ARE THE BACKBONE OF TREATMENT-
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL MANY COUNTIES
ALREADY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING
TO. TO COVER THE COST INCREASE
COST- VERTICALLY WE NEED FACTORY
WAGE INFLATION SO ADDING ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS. OUR FINANCIAL
BURDEN TO THE SCENARIO WILL HAVE
A BIG AFFECTED THE OVERALL
SERVICES THAT WE CAN PROVIDE NOW
TRY TO GO FASTER THESE- TO THESE
DATA POINTS YOU KNOW THEY'RE
ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY YOU ARE
OUT OF TIME RIGHT NOW. YEAH OKAY
WE'RE WE'RE NOT POSITION OKAY
THANK YOU AND PLEASE AND PLEASE
SEND THE DATA TO OUR COMMUNITY
STAFF ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
SEE NO ONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED I KNOW BUT IT
GOES FAST- WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
SO ANYONE WHO. WANTS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA- TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. DO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARINGS THINK KNOWLEDGE
CONSIDERATIONS I AM INSTITUTING
AGAIN A ONE MINUTE TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
EACH MEMBER PUBLIC PROVIDING
COMIC KEEP THEIR MARKS WITHIN
ONE MINUTE- YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND IT'S HELPFUL
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY WHICH ISSUE
AREAS THERE ON THE AGENDA THAT
YOU WISH TO ADDRESS AND THEN IF
YOU CAN IF YOU CAN S. GIVE YOUR
ENABLE TO COMPLETE YOUR COMMENT
pIN THE MINUTE PERIOD OF PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SEND A MORE
DETAILED COMMENT UP IN WRITING
TO OUR COMMITTEE STAFF. SO
PERHAPS THE VERBAL COMMENTS
SUGGEST THAT YOU STICK TO SERVE
THE HIGH LEVEL- THE DESCRIPTION
OF YOUR CONCERNS OR OR OR THINGS
THE SUPPORT AND- IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAIL PROVIDED
THROUGH A WRITTEN COMMENT- SO
WITH THAT- MODERATOR WE APPROVED
PLOT INDIVIDUALS WAITING PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- ONTO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LETTER PROVIDE PUBLIC.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOUR ON. WE
WILL GO UP TO LIKE FORTY FIVE
YOU'RE LINES OPEN THANK YOU.
HILLARY WITH CMA ON ISSUE FIVE
YOU MAY SUPPORT THE OVERALL
DIRECTION THE ADMINISTRATION
THINKS HE'S TAKING ON POWERHOUSE
WE APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
PAYMENT THIRTY REGARDLESS OF
MODALITY HOWEVER DESPITE
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AND COMMENT. THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE NOT BEEN ALTERED FROM
ITS ORIGINAL FORM AND CONCERNS
REMAIN. SUCH AS THE REQUIREMENT
THAT PROVIDERS OFFER VIDEO
TELEHEALTH AS WELL AS AUDIO.
PROVIDERS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
THAT LACK HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACCESS SUPPORT VIDEO THIS
REQUIREMENT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO ME
IT WILL CUT OFF ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICES IN THE AREAS
THAT NEED IT MOST. ON ISSUE
SEVEN CMA CONTINUES TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
EXTENDING IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COMPONENT OF CALLIN
TRANSITIONING TO ALL ELIGIBLE
MEDIC HOW AND MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES OUT OF VERY THIN
PLAN. FEMALE CONFIRMED THAT THE
H. THE ACTIVE ALREADY JUGGLING
MANY COMPLEX INITIATIVES AND
PRIORITIES THIS YEAR INCLUDING
OTHER COMPONENTS THE CALENDAR
WHICH MAY CREATE CHALLENGES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF A CHEF AT THE
FIVE SO. PUTTING THESE FRAGILE
ELDERLY BENEFICIARIES AT RISK
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU HAVE
COME FROM MY THIRTY. THANK YOU.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS TODD GURLEY
I'M THE CFO WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND I WAS GOING
INTO OPPOSE ITEM FOR JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE LOST SO MUCH
CAPACITY AND ALL OF THEM WE DO A
LOT OF OUTPATIENT AND
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND CO
BUT I NOW HAS. REALLY PUT A LOT
OF THE NONPROFIT IN THE RED WITH
NO PLANS ON HOW TO HELP GET THEM
OUT SO WE WOULD OPPOSE ANY
ADDITIONAL LICENSING FEES OR-
FEES AS WELL AS SUPPORTING THE
CABBIE AND CCAP P. CONSORTIUM.
BACK PHILIP RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT BOND STRONGER HELP US
ALL GET THROUGH THIS. OKAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT NEXT ONE S. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY SIX. I CAN'T
REMEMBER AS COMMUNITY RELATIONS
MANAGER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ANAHEIM LIGHTHOUSE WE ARE A
RESIDENTIAL BE PARKED BETWEEN
THE FACILITYAND OPPOSITION ITEM
FOR THE RESIDENTIAL OUTPATIENT
LICENSEE IN FINE FEE INCREASE-
WE ARE A BAD TO SAVE WHY WE
OPPOSE ITEM FOR INSTEAD OF
INCREASING LIKE BOOKING FEES FOR
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE R. O.
P. O. AB BACK BILL REQUEST. BUT
WE DO HAVE BEEN GREATLY AFFECTED
BY PROBATED AND- AFTER YOU- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE ITEM FOR HALF
BUT YOU- DO NOT APPROVE ITEM FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU COME FROM
LINE OF EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
TERROR THIS IS WHEN THE ARE. ON
IT FIVE. ON BEHALF WILL BE HELD
WHICH OPERATE FOUR KEY PROGRAM
PROGRAMS OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT CALIPHATE THIS
REQUEST ADELINE WHICH TO THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE. HELP
REBUILD. TO ENSURE THAT TAKE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN PERFORM PEACE
ELIGIBILITY ASSESSMENT VIA
TELEHEALTH. AND BEYOND BECAUSE
THEY MAKING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AND IT'S ALL THAT THE
CONNECTED REMOTELY ESTABLISH
TRUST THE BENEFICIARIES AT LEAST
TWENTY AND PROTECTING. YOUR FROM
CLOSER AND- EDVALD AND BEING
ABLE FOR BORN I IT'S ALL THE
FROM YOUR PAPER ABILITY HAS MADE
PEACE MARC FESTIVAL THE SENIOR
CAN BENEFIT. AND MORE MORE FUN
TO THE BODIES EITHER FOR THE YOU
CAN. CANNOT OR DO NOT WANT TO
TRAVEL AND WE BELIEVE THAT
BULLET THAT OF THE TRYING TO
BILL LANGUAGE WILL HELP FIX ACT
. AND ENSURE PEOPLE THEY CAN'T
CONTINUE TO AND PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE FOR THE AND FOR AMONG MOST
ROUTE. THAT THE VERSION FOR. AT
AND WE ARE STUCK TO. THANK THINK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE- THANK
YOU HAVE A COMPLAINT EIGHT AND
ONE OF OPEN. GOOD MORNING PAN
THIS FELIX- THE MANIFEST MATTER
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S.
CONGREGATION MIKE ACTS ABOUT-
THE BETWEEN THREE EITHER ON THE
- ISSUE ELEVEN ON THAT ACCOUNT
ENTERPRISE. ISSUE ON INTER
OPERABILITY WILL IMPLEMENTATION
AND ISSUE SEVEN ON CALENDAR. NOT
ONE WE ARE GLAD TO THE H. S. T.
A STAFF RESOURCE FOR IRAQ. IN CI
. THERE NEEDS TO BE MUCH MORE AT
A LOCAL LEVEL- FORGET MATHIS.
BACK REQUIRES EFFORT PEACE THERE
NINE ONE FEDERAL MATCH FOR I
HOPE THE NATION EXCHANGE UNDER
SURE LET AND FOR A ENTERPRISE
SYSTEMS. SO ASKING YOU- TO OUR
NAY FINAL DOLLARS SHOW WITH
PACKAGE INDUSTRY BUDGET- WILL
LEVERAGE CRITICAL HAS BOTHERS
ARE REQUIRE FOR MARCH THIRD. THE
PROPOSAL AND THAT'S AND YOUR
YOUR HAVE METTLER US- ABOUT THIS
. THANK THANK YOU THANK WITNESS. THANK YOU MIND THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS MAY FROM NUMBER AND-
DIRECTOR OF FALCON TAHOE
RECOVERY AND REBUILD. ONE TO
ENTER MY- TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT FUND
INCREASE THANK THAT LIVE OPPOSE
ADAM FOR. INSTEAD INCREASING
LIFE AND BE FOR TREATMENT
PROGRAM I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE ROP L. L. BACKED REQUEST
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU BETTER
COME FROM MINUS SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
NATHAN SAID MA'AM I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR ELEVATE
ADDICTION SERVICES- IN
OPPOSITION TO ITEM NUMBER FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUND R. O. B. L. S. B.
INCREASE. SAID THAT THEY'VE
LIVES OPPOSE ITEM FOR INSTEAD OF
INCREASING LICENSING FEES FOR
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS I
ASKED THE SUPPORT THE R. O. PL
LEFT BACK BILL REQUEST THANKS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THAT A
COMPROMISED. SEVENTY TWO. ONE
SEVENTY TWO DO YOU HAVE A
COMMUTE. I DID SORRY ABOUT THAT
HI MY NAME'S ARGUE OVER IT ON
THE LEGAL COMPLIANCE TO PROVIDE
YOUR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MONTEREY DAY RECOVERY AND
REHABILITATION IN OPPOSITION TO
ITEM FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSING FUND C.
INCREASED. STATE BED STABILIZE
THE POSING FOR INSTEAD OF
INCREASING LICENSING FEES FOR
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE R. O.
PL AFFECT THE REQUEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE. SEVENTY THREE. HELLO
MY NAME IS STILL IN ERRORS AND
I'M THE HR DIRECTOR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SKYLAKE RECOVERY IN
PUBLIC DAHLE IN OPPOSITION TO
ITEM NUMBER FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSE FEE FUND.
BEING CREATED SAVE THAT SAVE
LIVES OPPOSE ITEM FOR. THAT OF
INCREASING LIFE AND FEES FOR
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS
HI THAT YOU SUPPORT THE R. O. B.
THAT BACKED REQUEST THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS
. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALEX KLINE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ALKERMES- SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. GOVERNMENT INVESTMENT. WE
APPRECIATE THE AGE THE AT THE
COMMITMENT IN TODAY'S HEARING TO
ENSURE RESOURCES WILL BE USED TO
CONTINUE THE STATE POLICY OF
PARITY FOR ALL FDA APPROVED
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
HOWEVER AS REFLECTED ON PAGE
ELEVEN OF THE B. C. P. PROPOSED
FUNDING WOULD PRIORITIZE WAVERED
PRESCRIBERS. MEANING PRESCRIBERS
AND AMENITIES THAT ARE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE. AT THE
EXPENSE OF OTHER NON CONTROLLED
FDA APPROVED MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT. IN THE PAPER
UNPRECEDENTED OVERDOSES AND
DEATHS IT'S NOT INTHE BEST
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIANS TO
ELEVATE CERTAIN FDA APPROVED
TREATMENT OVER OTHERS THIS IS
THE DECISION APPROPRIATELY LEFT
TO PATIENTS AND THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. WE'VE SUBMITTED
SUGGESTED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE REVIEW AND
WE ALSO HAVE A PENDING MEETING
REQUEST WITH PHD AT AND HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO ALIGN ARE CONCERNED
BUT MORE DETAIL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU FOR MY SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ON BEHALF OF CAL PAGE
REGARDING ISSUE FIVE ON
TELEHEALTH POLICY WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
CONVERSATION THE ACS CARE
LANGUAGE THE TRAILER BILL TO
ENSURE PEACE ORGANIZATION CAN
PERFORM TELEHEALTH ASSESSMENT
PRIVILEGE ABILITY DETERMINATION
WHICH IS NOT THE CURRENT TRAILER
BILL. PAYTON RELIEF TO PEOPLE
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING. BERMAN
STATED PUBLISHING NEW PATIENT
COULD BE DONE FOR SYNCHRONOUS
VIDEO MELTED BILITY ASSESSMENT
IS THE FIRST STEP AND HELP
PEOPLE STAB. WISHES APPELLATION
CHECK. NUMBER LANGUAGES NEED TO
COVER BY NEED. RIGHT OR USE
FEDERALLY RUN ELIGIBILITY IF TO
ESTABLISH HUMAN ROWLEY'S DOING
ELIGIBLE ASSESSMENT THREE
TELEHEALTH DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY HELP KEEP
ENROLLING PEOPLE IN THE PACE
MEETING COULD MEDICALLY LOWER
COCA CREATES FOR PATIENTLY AND
OTHER TYPES OF CARE. HOW FROM
HER JUST APARTMENT TO LOOK AT
CMS ON A MINOR QUIBBLE APPROVAL
WHICH WILL HELP KEEP FAILED IN
EUROPE HELP YET HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND COMMUNITIES WE HOPE TO SEE
THE SIMPLE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
REQUEST IN THE TELEHEALTH
TRAILER BILL AND CONSUME NO
MATTER LETTER TO COMMITTEE IN
MARCH THANK YOU THANK. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU. FOR
MINUS SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
ON BEHALF OF HIS CLIENT ON
ISSUES TELEHEALTH FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR CONTINUATION OF
TELEHEALTH IN THE CONTINUATION
OF COVERAGE OF BOTH PHONE AND
VIDEO THAT THIS ACT UNITARITY
AND ACROSS PROVIDER TYPES
INCLUDING FOR FQHC. AFTER YEARS
TELL HELP IMPROVE VEHICLE
MODALITY PATIENTS AND PROVIDING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CARE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. IN ADDITIONAL DETAILS
TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDING THIS CRITICAL MODALITY
OF CARE INVESTORS PATIENTS.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR ELDERS INDEPENDENT
PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY SERVING
RESIDENTS OF ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. WE LIKE TO ECHO
THE- HELP HE COMMENTS REGARDING
TELEHEALTH WE WANT TO ENSURE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING TELEHEALTH
ASSESSMENTS FOR. ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION CHOPPY. ENCOURAGES
DEPARTMENTS WORK WITH THE M. F.
ON A MINOR FEDERAL APPROVAL
WHICH WILL HELP KEEP FRAIL
SENIORS HEALTHY HOME PLEASE%
REMAIN ON THEIR HEALTHCARE AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. IN THE
COMMUNITY WE HOPE TO SEE A COPY
ISSUE THE TRACKING AND THE
REVIVED WHICH IS. THANKS. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU COME
FROM EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MARK HUGHES ON THE OF
THE M. EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN AND AS
WITH THE COLD OF THE MEDIC HOW
DATA SHARING AT THE COALITION.
I'M CALLING IN REGARDS TO AN
ISSUE THAT IS RELEVANT TO ISSUE
SEVEN ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE LIKE THE
DIRECTION THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
ARE WORKING TOWARD A NEED TO BE
A BROADER VISION AND FUNDING
PATH FOR DATA SHARING TRICKS YOU
CALLIN GOALS. THAT INSPIRE
COALITION OPPOSED AND NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BUDGET
INVESTMENT TO ESTABLISH
INCENTIVES. FOR MEDIC HELP
PROVIDERS TO SHARE. COMPLETE
ACCURATE AND HEALTH FACTORED IN
FRONT OF A BUS INTEREST TO
MOVING USES DATA CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES. THIS REQUEST WILL
ALSO LEVERAGES GENEROUS RATIO OF
FEDERAL FARM. THE PROPOSAL
RICHARD ON MARCH THIRD I JUST
THOUGHT MAYBE. WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES JOIN US IN
CALLING FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO APPROVED A PROPOSAL IN THE
FINAL BUDGET ACTUALLY YEAH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU BETTER COME FROM MINE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING OUR SITE GOOD AFTERNOON
DR PANTAI RANDI ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY EDUCATION OF ALCOHOL AND
DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
REPRESENTING USES OR TREATMENT
PROVIDERS WERE IN OPPOSITION TO
ISSUE FOR ON THE AGENDA ON
INCREASE IN RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT ACTIVITY LICENSURE.
YOU'D BY 53% WE WOULD AGREEMENT
COMMENT BY BUT THE CHAIR AND DR
PAN ON THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF
BAD AS WE ARE TRYING TO LOOK AT
THE INCREASE THE CAPACITY ARE AT
HE TREATMENT THAT. CALIFORNIA'S
LOSING LICENSED AND CERTIFIED
STD TREATMENT PROGRAM YOU CAN
CRITICAL STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
THE NEED FOR SERVICE THAT WERE
UNDER INCUMBENT NINETEEN WITHOUT
A BACK SALE WHICH ARE PROPOSAL
FOR TWENTY MILLION GENERAL FUND
A ONE TIME OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. BUT HEARD IN YESTERDAY'S
BUDGET HEARING THE IMPACT LOAD
FACTOR BETA BLOCKER TREATMENT
PROGRAM INCREASED COST ALREADY
STRUGGLING PROGRAM AND
PREVENTATIVE TIONAL PROGRAM
COMING INTO THE FIELD WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
BACKFILL PREVENTING THAT THE
INCREASE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THAT'S WHAT THAT'S- THANK
YOU I EIGHTY FOR YEAR LETTER
OPEN. THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
SEAN JENKINS I'M THE CHIEF
OFFICER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
WEST CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO
ITEM NUMBER FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSING FEE
INCREASE. AT THE RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT PROVIDER IN AN AGENCY
OR CONTRACTS WITH RESIDENTIAL
AND OUTPATIENT PROVIDERS IN
THIRTY THREE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. THIS FEE INCREASE
WOULD BE A HARDSHIP ON AN
ALREADY STRESSED NETWORK PLEASE
SUPPORT THE BACKFILL REQUEST PUT
FORWARD BY CAT P. AND C. CAP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M AT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS NANCY ERAGON I KNEW
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE SOCIAIS DID
REHABILITATION PROGRAM FOR WOMEN
IN OPPOSITION OF ITEM FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUND THE INCREASED.
HEY FED SAVE LIVES AND OPPOSE
ITEM FOR INSTEAD OF INCREASING
LICENSING FEES FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS I ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT R. O. P. L. F. FACT
FILLED REQUEST. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY
NINETY FIVE A MONTH OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AM
COMMITTEE THIS IS ADRIAN SO
OFTEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
NUMBER THREE REGARDING THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS FUND I THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE SHIFT IN
OVERSIGHT AS WE BELIEVE IT IS
ALIGNED WITH THE UPCOMING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NINETY
EIGHT. SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO LINE AT NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY REGARDING BTS'S
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL WE SUPPORT
LANGUAGE TO MAKE PERMANENT SOME
OF THE TELEHEALTH FACILITIES AS
WELL AS STRENGTH IN CONSUMER
CONTENT LANGUAGE AND ABILITY
WITH. A TRANSLATION SERVICES
HOWEVER WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
NETWORK ADEQUACY LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN CONSUMER PROTECTION FIVE
STANDING ALTERNATIVE ACCESS
STANDARD FROM ANNUAL TO EVERY
THREE YEARS. TO MEDICARE MEMBERS
TRYING TO ACCESS WELL ACTUALLY
MAKE IT HARDER TO GET CARE- WE
REQUEST THE NETWORK ADEQUACY
PEACE BE DONE TO THE POLICY
PROCESS NOTING THERE'S ALREADY A
VEHICLE DR TAN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY.
IN ADDITIONAL EXPORT FUNDING FOR
INCREASED MONITORING AND
OVERSIGHT THAT CALTRANS FIVE
ISSUE EIGHT AND NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. Y. AND
ONE OH TO LINE IS. HELLO MY IS A
WAR NEWMAN- MAKE DIRECTOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
SOCIAL MODEL ADVOCATE IN
OPPOSITION TO ITEM FOR
RESIDENTIAL OUTPATIENT LICENSE
BEING KIND THE INCREASE. SAY BAD
STABILIZED PLEASE OPPOSE ITEM
FOR INSTEAD MEN CREATING
LICENSING FEES FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THAT ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THAT R. O. B. L. AT
BACK BILL REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WHY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ANDREA SAN MIGUEL ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATE THE CALIFORNIA CALLING
ABOUT ISSUE FIVE ON TELEHEALTH.
AND WE APPLAUD THE DECISION
REFLECTED IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THAT WOULD ALLOW
PATIENTS TO ESTABLISH KERR BY
SYNCHRONICITY- AND THE PAYMENT
PROVISION AS POINTED OUT BY
SHARE THIS DOES REPRESENT
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS BETWEEN THE
YEAH HOLDERS INCLUDING THROUGH
THE WORKGROUP AND MENTIONED THAT
TIME PEOPLE COULD PART AS- I
WANT YOU QUICKLY ALLIANCE THE
ANY COMMENT ABOUT THE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR VIDEO REQUIREMENT
CONCERNS. THE FOCUS ON A
DIFFERENT POINT WHICH IS THAT WE
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE ALLOWING
PATIENTS TO ESTABLISH KERR BY
PHONE AND EVEN PRINCIPALITIES
WHEN CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE THAT
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED FOR TWO YEARS
UNDER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WITHOUT THE
FLEXIBILITY PATIENTS SEEKING AND
THAT SERVICES SUCH AS BIRTH
CONTROL AND STI SCREENING. YOU
ARE PROTECTED UNDER CALIFORNIA
TREATMENT CHOICE POLICIES TO GO
OUTSIDE OF THEIR NETWORK WOULD
HAVE THEIR CHOICE RESTRICTED BY
THIS POLICY IF THEY LACK ACCESS
TO IN PERSON- VIDEO VISIT
THROUGH THEIR TYPICAL PROVIDER.
AND OF COURSE I'VE MENTIONED BY
SENATOR PANTHEA REQUIREMENT
COULD EASILY BE AN UNNECESSARY
CARE TOPATIENTS WITH SAFETY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY CONCERNS ARE
GETTING HOME- AND COURSE
TRANSPORTATION REMAINS A COMMON
BARRIERS TO HEALTH CARE FOR
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE WISHING VISIT
PLEASE WRAP OUR REQUIREMENT
REMAINS A LARGE CONCERN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERY MY NAME JENNIFER ARANGO I
BE YOU HE TALKED REPRESENT. FOR
CALLING HOCKEY OR COUNTY AND
ANGELES COUNTY AND- ITEM OR- AND
OUT LICENSING. THE INCREASE IT'S
ALREADY DIFFICULT ENOUGH TO WAIT
S. U. D. AND P. H. U. ATION
AFTER LEAVING OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEM WE CONSIDER SAVING THE
BED FADING THE FLY OUR LIVES AND
OPPOSE ITEM FOR ASK THAT. ARE
YOU ALL CONSIDER- INCREASING THE
LICENSING FEES FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM I
ASK YOU SUPPORT R. O. B. E. I'LL
HAVE BACK OVER FIVE. THANK YOU
ALL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU A LINE SIXTY
TWO YEAR AT THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JOANNE ON LAKE. FOR THE
DIFFICULT THANK YOU FOR MILLION
DOLLARS ON DATA SHOW UP FOR THE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE AND EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS RUBIO MERION ON
THE DIRECTOR PRIMARY CLICK HERE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CARAVAN OF
TREATMENT CENTERS AND WERE IN
OPPOSITION ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
EXCELLENT LICENSING FONG THE
INCREASE. HEY DAD SAVE LIVES.
ALL THE ITEMS FOR THE SUPPORT
THE FACT REQUIRE. FOR BY. YEAH
CAN'T BE ANTI CAP THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK WITNESS PLEASE.
LINE SIXTY FOUR YEAR ONE OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NORMA MARTINEZ I AM NOT- ONE OF
THE SUPERVISORS ALSO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TARZANA TREATMENT
CENTERS IN OPPOSITION TO- ITEM
NUMBER FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSING FUND FEE
INCREASE. ARE SAFE BETS THE
BLINDS AND A FULL ITEM NUMBER
FOUR PLEASE SUPPORT THE BACK THE
REQUEST PUT FORTH BY KATHY AND
THE CAP THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PRINT BY FORTY TWO. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
OKAY YEAH- HI MY NAME IS A LOT
OF ARRIVAL I AM THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT YOU KNOW PATIENT
COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO- AND I'M
CALLING- IN OPPOSITION TO IRAN
FOR RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
MY COOKING FUNDS. ARE BEING
INCREASED THE BAD STABILIZE
OPPOSE ITEM FOR INSTEAD OF
INCREASING LICENSING FEES FOR
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM I
ASK FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THE R. O.
PL AND ACTUAL REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SO FIVE YOU'RE ONE
OF OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN HOW WE CAN
SECTOR-LIMÓN SPEAKING OF THE
STAKEHOLDER ON- OF THE MEDICAL
DATA SHARING EQUITY COALITION WE
REPRESENT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
HEALTH PLANS HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES JOINTLY COMMITTED THIS
EXACT. AND DATE HEARING NEED TO
CALAIS I'M REFERENCING THREE
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA- THEY ARE
ALL RELATED TO MY OVERALL
COMMENT ISSUE SEVEN ELEVEN AND
THIRTEEN OUR COALITION IS
PROPOSING NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET INVESTMENT
ESTABLISHED. AN INDIGENOUS FOR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO SHARE
COMPLETE ACCURATE AND TIMELY
HEALTH RECORDS AND FUND ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MOVE AND USE
THAT DATA THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES. I REQUEST WILL
LEVERAGE GENEROUSLY ENHANCE
FEDERAL FUNDS IT WAS HEARD ON
MARCH THIRD BY THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
AS A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
BACKED BY MANY STAKEHOLDERS WE
URGE YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN US IN CALLING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCLUDE OUR
DATA SHARING EQUITY PACKAGE IN
THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT ARE FROM MY
NINETY YEAR IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LISA BIKER AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ALPHA OPEN
CORNERSTONE RECOVERING- I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO ITEM NUMBER FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUND C. INCREASE SAY
THAT SAVE LIVES OPPOSED ITEM FOR
PLEASE. INSTEAD OF INCREASING
LICENSING FEES FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS I ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE R. O. PL LEFT
BACK BILL REQUEST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANDREA FULLER AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES HERE CALLING FROM
ON BEHALF OF TARZANA TREATMENT
CENTERS IN OPPOSITION OF ITEM
FOR RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUN THE INCREASE.
FAITH BAD SAVE LIVES OPPOSED
ITEM NUMBER FOUR PLEASE SUPPORT
THE BACK BILL REQUEST TO PUT FOR
THIS CD THE AB P. AND C. C. A.
T. THANK YOU THANK YOU YOUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU HAVE A
COMPROMISED. FIFTY FIVE. MY
FIFTY FIVE YOU HAVE A PHONE YOU. I'M SORRY ON AND ABLE TO HEAR
YOU. OKAY WE WILL WANT TO LINE
AT NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR PAN THIS IS DOCTOR
FISHMAN TAYLOR CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF CENTERPOINT REGARDS
TO USE UP THE PANEL FOOD FROM
THE KEYPAD. I'M CALL TALK TODAY
STRONG. TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR THE
INCREASE IN FEES FOR LICENSURE-
WE DON'T THINK THAT AT 63%
INCREASE. IN FEE STRUCTURE FOR
PROVIDERS IS EQUITABLE GIVEN
THAT THERE IS NOT A SIMILAR
INCREASE IN REVENUE FOR
PROVIDERS THAT ARE PROPOSED
ACROSS THE BOARD. YOU KNOW WITH
THE STATE HAVING A BUDGET
SURPLUS I BELIEVE THAT THERE
THAT WE WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO FIND AN ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
MECHANISM. RATHER THAN THE SELF
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT AT
CURRENTLY FISCAL LICENSURE
SURELY THERE'S A CREATIVE WAY.
THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH- TRYING
TO- KEEP. THE TREATMENT. THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST FROM GOING
BANKRUPT AND FROM CLOSING THEIR
DOORS WE'VE LOST ENOUGH
TREATMENT PROGRAM. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO
INCREASE CAPACITY RESIDENT
REDUCING. AND BY NOON PLEASE
WRITE PLEASE REFERENCE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. WE WILL- DEFINITELY
URGE YOU TO DO YOUR BEST I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THANK THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BALDWIN AND I AM DID EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER OF LEGACY
ALLIANCE OUT OF REACH AND WE I'M
CALLING BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
OPPOSITION TO FREE INCREASED-
BASICALLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU KNOW THE FINANCIAL DISPARITY
OF FINANCIAL ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE WE HAVE TO FIND MORE
CREATIVE WAYS THAN JUST RAISING
THE RATES- IF WE BREAK IF YOU
RAISE THE RATES. IN YOU IN YOU
READY TO WRITE CERTAIN CREAMS
RESIDENTIAL I THINK THESE GOING
TO REDUCE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE HOUSING
AND RECOVERY SERVICES WHICH IS
GOING TO INCREASE. IMMIGRATION
INCARCERATION AND IF IS BY.
DECISION IT WILL BE ABOUT HOW TO
DESIGN IT WILL HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL HAND AND THE
VICTIMIZATION OF OTHERS ON ON
CALIFORNIA'S ANYTHING HUMAN
BEINGS WE WANT TO REDUCE THAT
NOT INCREASE THAT AND SO WE'RE
OPPOSITION TO ARMED. RESIDENTIAL
IN WASHINGTON THREE INCREASED-
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO FIND
SMALL TARGET METHODS I THANK YOU
THANK YOU READY. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THAT BILL I SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY IS NICOLE TO
YOU FROM OUR MANAGER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF FRED BROWN RECOVERY
SERVICES IN OPPOSITION TO ITEM
FOR RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUND FEE INCREASE SAVE
BIRDS SAVE LIVES. OPPOSE ITEM
FOR INSTEAD OF INCREASING
LICENSING FEES FOR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS I ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE R. O. PL LEFT
BACK BILL REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- I AGAIN PEOPLE ARE OF
COURSE FREE TO TESTIFY WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT WE'VE HEARD
NUMEROUS TESTIMONY ON ITEM FOUR
IN OPPOSITION- THAT THEY CAN
ALMOST RECITE YOUR LINES FOR
YOU. SO IF YOU IT'S A FEW WHICH
JUST SAY THAT YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION AND THAT YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT THE- BACK FILL- THAT'S
FINE- SO- BUT- WILL JUST
CONTINUE- AND CERTAINLY WE DO
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU- BUT- JUST
MAKE NOTE THAT WE'VE REFERRED
NUMEROUS- SIMILAR TESTIMONY ON
ON THAT ITEM ALREADY SO- AND-
HOPEFULLY THAT CHANCE TO HEAR
DISCUSSIONS AND THE HEARING AS
WELL WHERE. I THINK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALSO RAISE
SOME QUESTIONS AS TO THE- THAT
IS TO SAY THAT ISSUE AS WELL
BUT- MODERATOR HOW MANY HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE STILL ON THE LINE. WE
HAVE SIX OKAY LET'S PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT LINE ONE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICK
TRUJILLO. I AM FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN TRAINING INSTITUTE ON
THE OWNER AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CLEANING INSTITUTE. AND I'M
APPROVING THE INCREASE IN FEES
FOR THE RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM WHEN
LICENSING. SO OPPOSED TO ITEM
FOUR AND THEN FADE BED THREE
LIVES. SEARCH LOCAL POST BATTLE
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE ONE TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BRANDON FERNANDES AND I'M THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER OF CRY
HELPING TO NORTH HOLLYWOOD
OPERATOR OF RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT SERVICES
AND I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR- RATES. FOR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS HERE IN L. A.
COUNTY WERE JUST RELEASED
YESTERDAY AND RESIDENTIAL FEES
REIMBURSEMENT INCREASING BY LESS
THAN THREE AND A HALF PERCENT
BASED ON OUR CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE IT IS
NOT FEASIBLE TO PAY AN INCREASE
IN OUR LICENSE OR RATE OF SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. PLEASE SUPPORT
THE BACK BURKE BUT BEFORE IF I
CATCH HIM TO DROP. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE A
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME OUT WHAT THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR- AFTER. READING ENOUGH
THAT I'D END UP FOR RESIDENTS OF
WEALTHY LIKE FUNDING THE
INCREASE. THE BED IT BY BOTH OUT
OF SEVEN CREEK LIKE YOU READ
THAT THE PROGRAM THAT. ARE O. P.
O. AFFECTED BY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WHY ONE
YEAR LINE A OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS REBECCA IN AND THEY DIRECTOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF TO OPTIMIZE
HEALTH A WHOLE IN OPPOSITION
ITEM. READ THE AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSING FUND INCREASE SAVE BED
THEY LIVE OPPOSE ITEM FOR
INSTEAD OF INCREASING LICENSES
FEES FOR RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAMS I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
R. O. P. L. AND BACK THE REQUEST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WHY MORE TWELVE
YEAR ON OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GINA
SMITH ON THE NURSE LIAISON FROM
LEGACY ALLIANCE OUT REACH I'M
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO ITEM FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT LIFE
AND FIND INCREASE DAVID SAVE
LIVES INSTEAD OF THE INCREASE.
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR OPL ACCENT SO
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THE LAST ONE CHAIR IS ONE OH
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN YOU STILL
HEAR ME TALK WITH HIM. PLEASE
BEGIN HELLO. HELLO. MA'AM HE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. OH I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY THANK YOU-
YOU'RE THIRTY. JANE WITH THE ARE
USE AND YOUR MENTAL HEALTH-
MOVEMENT- ARE YOU CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO ITEM THREE- I HAVE
GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT BEING
A CHARGE QUICKLY TO A TRAILER
BILL- IN REMOVING OVERSIGHT FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION- WE.
WE HAVE A- YOU YEAR THE FARMS
REPS HAVE CO OPTED CALIFORNIA
MENTAL HEALTH MOVEMENT AND- YOU
KNOW. SURE AFTER WE HAVE HEALTH
SERVICES ARE IN- NEARLY
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL HAS HAS
DIRECTED CHAPTERS ACROSS AMERICA
FIFTY USING. THE TERM WARM WINDS
. THE FEW WEEKS AGO IS VANCE OF
A CONTINUE OF ROLLING OUT AS A
NON PRIVATE- CRISIS LINE THAT
WILL BE MANAGED IN ANOTHER STATE
WITH LESS PRIVACY- IS THAT
RAISES HUGE PRIVACY CONCERNS FOR
ME AND I'M PLEASE. WRAP OTHER
PEERS. AND- SB NO THIS. CAMPAIGN
WOULD HAS DOUBLE NO YOU KNOW
THROUGH PREVENTION BUT ALSO KNOW
THE SIGNS OF A SO G. AND A
PATHWAY TO WRAP UP SOON. SO
RIGHT. AND OKAY I DO WE IN YOUR
YEAH I RECOVER OR OKAY
HEARTENING OF MENTAL HEALTH WITH
RATE BIG PHARMA THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- YOU'RE AT THE I. V. CAN
DECIMATE YOUR OF MY AND- RIGHT
SINCE YOU WENT OVER TIME WITH
THE- SO WE- HAVE IT FOR RECORD
THAT DON'T. SHE ADDED. HEY HOW
MY- NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR- I WOULD
AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED AND
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY OR
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A FURTHER
REMARKS THAT YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
MAKE GIVEN OUR TIME CONSTRAINTS
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW. COMMITTEE
AND SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS SO
AGAIN THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WANNA THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE COOPERATION AGAIN WANT
TO THANK OUR- COMMITTEE STAFFER
SERGEANTS TO ADHERE IN ROOM AND
OF COURSE OUR MODERATORS AS
WELL- TO ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE
OF ACCESS TO- THIS. IMPORTANT
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL ROUTE- REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE BUT
THAT WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR
AGENDA AND THIS HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCES
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.